what what just happened like YouTube
picked up like the pre-show I was
talking about making a video game and
like open source rules or something I
hope people heard it it's like hot Mike
Tim's talking about making a game I was
talking about my hair sticking out talk
about your hair singing like yeah I
think that's what's embarrassing
so Stephen Crowder put out a response to
Jeremy boring's response um let me give
you the gist you've got two uh
juggernauts in independent
anti-establishment conservative media
space Crowder is accusing the daily wire
the daily
wires co-ceo Jeremy boring issue
response Stephen Crowder just issued
another response and the drama is
heating up and in this response Crowder
posted clips of a phone call he had with
Jeremy boring which is now just lighting
up the drama even more because you've
got some people saying they don't like
what Jeremy said but a lot of people
pointing out that you know why did
Stephen record Jeremy boring's phone
call in the first place it's like that's
kind of a you know I don't know man
people are not happy that that happened
so we're going to talk about all this
and uh this is also lighting up in
mainstream press it's like the big con
the the drama between Stephen Crowder
and the daily wire and uh you know it's
convenient for us that right after the
speakers vote we're like man there's no
news and all sudden this drama hold my
beer yeah so uh we're gonna talk about
that but we do have news we have a lot
of stuff out of the world economic Forum
Al Gore saying that he like went on this
like he may as well held up a sign
saying the end is an eye with a scraggly
beard on the side of a highway screaming
about how it's all coming to an end
because it was like an unhinged rant and
it's funny coming from a guy who like 20
years ago said we had 10 years or
whatever so like okay man calm down like
we want to be good stewards of the Earth
but saying it's going to rain bombs and
people are like a billion refugees are
going to storm countries slow down there
buddy and then we got them saying that
there will be a ban on Free Speech in
this country so we'll talk about that
plus Alec Baldwin
my friends I told you
you know what they said first of all
he's being charged and then voluntary
manslaughter and they found live ammo
and where did they find it well there
was some like in the in the box of ammo
there was some lying around and there
was live ammo in Alec Baldwin's gun belt
that he was wearing so when y'all say
like but how could the bullet have
gotten to the gun I don't know maybe the
guy who shot the gun had the bullet on
him had bullets on him okay I'm gonna go
off on this because we talked a lot
about Alec Baldwin last year when it
happened so we'll talk about that before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
directly as a member you get access to
exclusive uncensored segments from the
show hey look my voice is mostly back
and as a member you a lot me sick time
because you know you're basically
supporting the the longevity of this
company and then when I'm not able to
not able to talk I can relax and try and
get my voice back but uh we'll have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you tonight which should be really
awesome and uh you support our other
shows and our cultural Endeavors I got I
got an announcement to make let me uh
let me grab this
this is looking good ladies ladies and
gentlemen uh soon to be available Tim
cast skate company skateboards all all
thanks to you we were able to make these
and look at this really amazing a logo
that's that's our that's our logo it's a
cool tee that's it's yeah it's a llt for
timcast and a lot of people were like I
don't like the name Tim Kess is dumb and
I was like we can call it Redskins
skateboard we can call it Redskins Aunt
Jemima's [ __ ] skateboards because
these companies for those that aren't
familiar that logo used to be the logo
of one of the most iconic skateboard
brands in the world until woke people
got mad at them called them racist and
they dropped it and so my attitude is
they've abandoned the logo they don't
want to use it they find it racist I
will use it and if they have a problem
they're free to send me a letter that's
what you're supporting when you become a
member you know what we're gonna do next
we're going to launch launch Aunt
Jemima's [ __ ] skateboards and if they
got a problem with with icons and names
that they don't use anymore then they
can send me a letter to but I will make
the legal argument in court if I have to
you abandon your logo we can use it so
we'll be selling these skateboards first
thank you you all for being members
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more is Candace Owens hello
hello it's lovely to be back here so uh
everybody knows who you are but I guess
you just gotta introduce yourself anyway
my name is Candace Owens just as he said
I would like to confirm that statement
tell me more
I would like to also first say that this
was not planned a part of this thing
that blew up this week we booked me on
for this exact night before the end of
last year so it just happened to be that
I am on when all of this drama is
unfolding with the daily wire and
Stephen Crowder there's people on the
plot they don't they don't know you are
are you on contract with the daily wires
out as you employ with the daily wire
I'm not an employee I am contracted uh
you know I do my show on the my podcast
show five days a week on The Daily wire
and I've now been doing that for almost
three years I think two three years yeah
cool right on well we we definitely got
to talk about the Crowder stuff because
before we went live you were just going
off about all this stuff and there's a
lot to say so we'll get into that we got
Luke hanging out hey guys my name is Sue
kardowski here of we are change.org and
the world economic Forum hates your
freedom I love my freedom and I value it
especially in this field with all the
crazy stuff happening right now I've
been independent since day one I'm still
independent right now at all costs and
that's why I may made this shirt that
reads I tested positive for Freedom
which you could exclusively get and
support me at the same time on the best
politicalshirts.com because you do
that's why I'm here thank you again so
much for having me Ian Crossland from
Ian crossland.net what's up everybody
Candice great to see you again always a
pleasure always a pleasure let's get
down to this search yeah I am at
surge.com always happy to see you it's
gonna be a good episode so let's go all
right so here's the uh the first story
that we have and this one's gonna get
spicy we got this video clip from
Stephen Crowder titled I didn't want to
do this Crowder has issued a response to
Jeremy boring's response in it Stephen
Crowder releases some audio notably uh
well let me let me see if I can play
this do we have the audio properly set
up yep
here we go we'll play the beginning
they don't get deals that
they see wave slaves for a little bit
[Applause]
God bless the talk boy those things are
almost like five thousand dollars now
it's an expensive gag
um that is kind of crazy I didn't
realize they were so expensive all right
before YouTube so I used to do it this
is I mean this is gonna this is a tough
one uh Steven's not here to defend
himself but Candace is here to to give
her perspective on this so I'll just
throw it to you and give me your
thoughts on on his response and what
happened with the daily wire because I
know you got a lot to say I do have a
lot to say about this because obviously
the situation impacted me and impacted
all of the other hosts on The Daily wire
so first of all I feel like I just want
to say this which is that I have never
once I've been with daily wire two to
three years now you have never once
heard me come out to defend the daily
wire on anything this is not the first
time Dilly wire has been in a firestorm
or has been had some beef that has gone
on whether it's for Ben or Matt or
Michael that's going on the last three
years I tend to stay very much in my
Lane as I mentioned before I'm not an
employee of a daily wire I'm not
required to come out and defend them and
I'm usually just not interested in these
beefs that seem to be so fickle they
last for a day and then they go away and
it's probably the reason why for
whatever doesn't really matter anybody
thinks got me I have a good relationship
with pretty much everybody like there's
no one that I can't be invited and be in
the same room with everybody sort of
hates each other but I'm kind of I can
Alex Jones has a good opinion of me
everyone from Alex Jones to Ben Shapiro
Paul Joseph Watson Mike cernovich is
somebody that I call and ask for advice
from time to time Jack wasobic like I
I'm a kind of person that judges People
based on how they treat people right I'm
not interested in dabbling in this
nonsense
um nonsense from time to time it appears
and then goes away and Ebbs and flows
this situation though was different
because basically Stephen Crowder
decided to launch a war and didn't
really care who got hit you know with
the shrapnel right he comes out he makes
this glorious video which it's shocking
to me that people cannot see the amount
of acting that is going into this we all
understand it's a childhood actor he was
on I loved that show Arthur he was the
brain like he he is an actor at the end
of the day as an actor it's also why
he's so entertaining when it comes to
politics he's a talented person but that
people cannot discern the amount of
action that has gone on and this is
stunning to me I don't know where
people's discernment what's going on
with discernment where you can't just
spiritually discern that this feels a
little weird right you're recording
conversations with someone that you have
told us you are friends with forever oh
and by the way at the end of you saying
that you're just trying to do the right
thing you're also saying I'm going to
launch my own thing right so just when I
first saw the first video that he
dropped obviously I'm not privy to
negotiations that happened on The Daily
wire I had no idea they were negotiating
with Stephen Crowder again not my
business I came into work one day
suddenly Brett Cooper was there not
movies I don't know who they're hiring I
don't own the company right but what I
started getting was after I had dropped
my podcast in the comment section
everyone was basically tearing me apart
being like blink twice if you need help
first thing like I'm a hostage situation
or saying what if you don't say anything
about Stephen Crowder you're a fraud
you're a fraud just like suddenly you're
a fraud you're a fraud so I go and I
watch this video and just like everybody
else watching it live his first video
your instincts are like whoa he's
throwing some bombs he's calling it big
con he's saying essentially that we are
enslaved by these contract terms he
actually uses the term enslavement if
you don't want to be a slave you know
you may be a co-worker I'm going to
figure it out for all of us like you're
a hero you're a martyr and because I was
getting so many comments the first thing
I did was that I messaged my EP and I
said we have to cover this tomorrow on
the show because now everyone thinks I'm
a fraud and they think that I've signed
with fraudulent terms or slave-like
terms and that's so totally unfair to me
so my interest in this is that it hit me
and it hit everybody else the daily wire
and it was unfair do you I don't know
you don't have to answer this I guess
but do you have a similar contract there
are certain terms I recognize that's why
I immediately knew was daily wire so for
example the um the fee reduction if you
miss a day of work right like if you
miss a day of work we are paying for x
amount of episodes and this is a steep
amount if you miss one day of work when
you first see that when I first received
a contract from a daily wire I went
that's a shocking number to see then you
have to calculate and by the way mine
was not this one to be very clear I
don't have a 50 million dollar contract
if there's anything I should be upset
about is that they were going to pay
that much Stephen Crowder right I need
to go renegotiate my contract but so you
see it and it's shocking and then you
read under which is what he did not
include when he says so if I get hit by
a car like I'm just gonna a hundred
thousand dollars a day he didn't tell
you how much he made you don't 100 000
means unless you can see what were they
offering him and you can calculate
yourselves okay so what they're
basically saying is that we're paying
you sixty three thousand dollars a day
you know what I'm saying he he purposely
like excluded right beneath it that says
that actually it's Pro rata it's an
event of an emergency that's a very
insignificant thing that would allow
people not to be enraged at seeing this
yeah just to clarify Jeremy when Jeremy
uh released his video he showed the the
additional portion that said in the
event of temporary disability they
prorate you there's no penalty and then
we talked about this last night I said
the hundred thousand dollars seems
punitive I think you mentioned yeah but
what about daily wires cost I said oh
yeah Fair Point DC drainage and that is
exactly right they have all of these
contracts that exist it's very easy to
understand we're paying you here's this
is hundred thousand dollars we're paying
you sixty three thousand dollars for the
content they are also have a bunch of
contracts everybody's working on the
show so for example my EP she's
contracted I don't know what her
contract says maybe it says that no
matter what she is guaranteed this
amount of money so if I magically call
out they still have to to pay her they
still have to pay the camera guy maybe
the advertising is punitive if you
didn't give us the content the
advertisers maybe then say okay you joyr
should pay us five thousand dollars of
cash doesn't read ads on that day you
don't know when you have an organization
this big what everybody's contracts are
so I assume it's sixty thousand dollars
and then they're baking in an extra 38
000 to cover their assets to pay
everybody else that maybe showed up for
work that day but Jeremy did say
punitive it is because he said well
you're right about the costs all around
it but he said he basically said one
circumstance is you're choosing not to
work and one is you're unable to work
right if you're unable we get it we'll
just we'll just prorate based on the
Lost day but he also says it'll be
interesting that you could you could
make up that day by banking it at any
time right so I do that by the way I do
that and that's why it's so annoying so
I see these things it's to people who
don't know how this works first and
foremost it's a term sheet he was never
given a contract it was a term street
it's essentially a a starting
conversation here's what we have in mind
and everything's baked in some things
literally don't make sense like in my
term sheet it said you know we uh
whatever about they wanted access to my
Snapchat I don't have a Snapchat they
wanted access to my room I don't have a
rumble they don't access it's literally
just like here's something so we can get
the conversation started started and
really I think you need to pay attention
to is is like this is the money and then
of course our lawyer is gonna go back
and say this makes entirely no sense
this makes entirely no sense so then you
get to you know personalize it so to
speak right when you say okay well this
thing makes me nervous because okay what
if it's not me that's sick but my son I
have two kids right what if my son
breaks his leg and I have to be I'm not
gonna not leave his side so I have to I
have to then say I need to personalize
this term sheet and that is what the
contract is done for if you come to some
agreement that this is what we're going
to work on right this is what we're
going to negotiate in good faith right
so he first and foremost lied by saying
it was a contract he lied by Omission by
not saying how much money so people
couldn't calculate okay really how
punitive is that 100 000 not that much
and you consider that there's a bunch of
costs that go in to producing a show and
and people that they may have paid
editors in this case he produces his own
show but you know editors writers no
matter what the daily wire has to see
that package and do something to it so
and by the way like I said we know it's
at least standard so it's not because
they're trying to hit Stephen Crowder
they've given this to all of us and your
job then if you're a big boy right if
you can put on your big boy pants is to
go to your lawyer and to say I'm not
doing that I'm not doing that this makes
no sense negotiate now if you are a
young talent that was discovered on
YouTube as I was way back in the day who
comes from no money as I was way back in
the day this could be like unfair
because I can't afford a lawyer to go
through line by line of this and Redline
this that is not the circumstance
receiving Crowder he's already told us
he's got so much money he's more
successful and he doesn't need the money
blah blah blah so why don't you just
hire a lawyer but that that's what he
said in the rebuttal yeah it's not about
me it's about the daily wire signing new
upcoming young people to these terms and
they don't and and that and in that
capacity he hits Brett Cooper right now
he's basically so who who is a young
upcoming talent that got signed there's
only what five hosts of shows on my
daily wire here I mean so you're talking
about Matt Walsh no he's not young
upcoming Talent that's just been signed
you're talking about Michael Knowles no
he's not young you're not talking about
cancer I don't think we would say Andrew
Clavin is Young upcoming Talent so
you're talking about Brett Cooper that's
insulting to Brett Cooper you have no
idea what he's just saying [ __ ] right
and it's not like he's reached out to us
and said hey like I'm doing this for all
of us like it's not he reached out
independently to daily wire host and
been like are you dealing with disagreed
these egregious terms no he is doing
this purely let's not even try to make
this anything but a selfish act that was
to benefit Stephen Crowder who wants to
launch his own network because and by
the way I gotta say this is the most
important part of this and nobody is
talking about this he receives the term
sheet okay and he thinks it's so
egregious that he's got to make this
video four months later right I don't
know what happened in those four months
after they started negotiating I guess
Stephen Crowder woke up New Year knew me
I hate I hate the daily wire so I'm
gonna go after them he thinks it's so
egregious the first thing he does is
counter offer and say let's start
talking about 140 million okay so if it
was so outrageous why did he go back to
them and say no actually we can have
this conversation but let's start
talking about 140 million right it was
only when the daily wire then turned
that down that the term sheet became so
egregious that he had to do something
about it I'll just add real quick to
everybody Stephen Crowder is coming on
the show on Monday I know he's not here
to defend himself did you speak to him
because he might have recorded your
conversation
I mean yeah my view is I was kind of
surprised to hear that Stephen recorded
the phone call with Jeremy because um I
don't I don't know why you would
um by the way it should be mentioned
that conversation so they stopped
negotiating completely which Jeremy made
clear in his video this was over he
doesn't even know what this was coming
from because this this conversation
stopped when Stephen Crowder then came
back with a counter term sheet offer of
what a glorious 140 million dollars over
x amount of years and they said we just
can't do this right then he sat and he
stewed and he said nothing until one
week ago he reaches out to Jeremy and he
asks him to talk on the phone and that
was one week ago that is the
conversation that you are guys are all
hearing that he is playing right now so
he plotted this this is a plot line he
planned to then record him to go back
and to make this video If this if he had
recorded this way back during
negotiations maybe you could say there
was no plot why did he reach out to
Jeremy exactly one week ago when they
hadn't discussed anything pertaining to
the contract and they said no one walked
away last year around October November
and then suddenly in January he reaches
out when we can go and says hey can we
get on the phone and he decides maybe I
should record this no it's because he
realized he had nowhere left to go and
his next plot in this storyline in this
terrible childhood acting he's doing
right now was okay I have to do my own
thing now and so I need to drum up some
drama to get everybody that I know to
believe and I am a martyr for our
beliefs and they should dump their
subscriptions to everybody else it's
part of VidCon and join the mug Club how
can people not see I mean the writing is
just so on the wall the fact that he
recorded Jeremy says that he did plan
look I'm not I'm not here to impugn his
arm honor I think you're absolutely
entitled to your view having you know
working with the daily wire and
everything you've seen but uh it like it
does suggest that he knew he was calling
Jeremy for this reason I think I think
Crowder is um I don't I don't know if I
I think it might be too far for me to
believe that Crowder is trying to do
this to pull subscribers from daily wire
or make more money for himself because
the Dude already makes a lot of money
but not he he does not he thinks that he
is worthy of 140 million dollars a year
do you believe that Stephen Crowder
right now is making 140 million dollars
I bet he could you bet he could
absolutely you bet he could but how's he
got to do that how's he got to start
that he just had a couple of kids how's
he going to start that you launch a war
in a conservative movement and you move
people away from a business that you
want to model you know I don't know
who's modeling who I don't know who
started this first but you basically say
I'm not them come with me and that's
exactly what he's doing call a spade a
spade call a spade a spade okay this was
a plot line and that annoys me because
he dragged me into this plot line okay
he dragged us all into this pot line
he's basically saying oh well he at one
point in his video this is what really
set me off he's like and so you might be
noticing that a lot of these people
um their viewpoints are sanitized and
this is why this contract this is why
essentially saying that Candace is
controlled Matt Walsh is controlled
Michael Knowles is controlled Brett
Cooper is controlled and now we know why
guys because I have this contract which
I've conveniently extraordinated
portions that could allow you to discern
for yourself it's actually not that
unreasonable as a starter to
conversation which is what a term sheet
is right and instead I'm just going to
smear all these people that are
associated wire and that's why I'm
pissed off that's why I'm pissed off
because I then was Fielding comments
calling me a fraud because they thought
that I agreed to these terms and that my
voice was being controlled
you know I told Stephen I said
um I think ideologically I understand
he's right with the contracts and I and
I agree with the contracts we don't we
don't do contracts the way the daily
wire does there was no contractor just
want to say that one more well right so
uh contract different term
um terms I don't do terms the way the
daily wire does I also am you know the
way it's it's like The Joe Rogan story I
often tell that he booted me from a show
twice and I didn't get mad at him I was
like well I'm kind of I'm kind of pissed
off that he he booted me twice like
happened twice and I flew out to LA but
he doesn't know many favors I'm not
going to rag on Joe Rogan because he
didn't do me a favor if I was on a show
be really great for me it didn't work
out I'm going to carry on with my life
and my business I've negotiated with the
daily wire we couldn't we couldn't
figure out something that worked we're
very different in that sense and I said
well you know it was nice hanging out
and let's let's work on stuff in the
future and we'll make awesome stuff I
told Stephen I said I think that the
daily wire is a massive net positive
especially with like what is a woman I
mean that was a massive cultural force
that got even made mainstream like
moderate Lefty types to be like oh yeah
I've seen that and start this
conversation uh then you did the BLM
documentary of course that had uh I I
don't think it was nearly as big as what
as a woman but certainly had a cultural
response these things are tremendous and
so magnitude is like look
I don't I don't I don't like the the
contracts of like they're very they're
very business-like the very
entertainment industry
I understand that the daily wire that
daily wire does it if someone came to me
and said we're going to get investors
we're going to get some prominent
conservative voices and we're going to
launch a company that Rivals Disney I'd
be like man I don't like Disney and
they'll go yeah yeah but it will be
America loving independently minded
meritocratic I'll say oh I'll take that
over Disney any day and then I'll go and
do my thing that I think should be the
way I want it to be and I'm not gonna be
mad at the daily wire for the daily wire
doing a thing like yeah Bill what you're
describing first and foremost are the
free markets right if you don't like it
somewhere leave I thought we were
conservatives I thought that's what
you're trying to preserve right a free
market mentality if this if daily wire
is so awful right and so predatory and
treating their talent so horrifically
they'd have no Talent right then
literally Stephen Crowder wouldn't have
to launch a war you just have to launch
an alternative business with better
contract and people would leave
willingly they would say there's more
money there there's better treatment I'm
leaving that's what the free markets
work right because he did not feel maybe
he's feeling a little insecure he
thought that he was a free agent he
feels like he's Tom Brady everyone's
gonna make me all these offers and he
thought he became an extremely low Tom
Brady I'm Tom Brady why am I getting
offered 50 million dollars that should
be offered 140 million dollars and the
team says no thank you Tom Brady and
then he goes oh I'm effing Tom Brady
well the truth is it's like I think
Stephen Crowder was feeling insecure I
think he was reeling after those
negotiations I think there are very few
conservative networks that can offer him
that money he's actually you know he's
burned a few Bridges right Fox News he's
burned a bridge he's burned a bridge
with the police how many other companies
in the conservative movement does he
think can reasonably afford to pay him
what he thinks he's worth right the
daily wire so when he was done I think
that he was feeling tremendously
insecure right when those negotiations
failed in October or November he stewed
on it in November in December came up in
January and decided okay I'm gonna have
to launch my own outfit I'm gonna go
after the daily wire and his plot line
included calling Jeremy Boren catching
him on camera on on we only have seen a
piece of his conversation Jeremy has
already tweeted that he called him like
hey let's catch up and then and now he's
he was like let's talk about the kids
and Christmas they were friends very
close friends Okay so Stephen Crowder
has said they were friends not
colleagues not Associates not you know
like I would say me and Matt Walsh and
what were Associates but friends he
called his friend to talk about
Christmas and his kids and instead he
recorded him and then dropped that
recording a week later pretending that
he was doing this to to be a martyr I
just don't see how people don't realize
this guy is a bad a fundamentally bad
person like I I don't understand how
this is even a debate the phone call
thing's rough I mean Who records their
friends with friends like these who
needs enemies who needs the left and
we've got friends like these in the
conservative movement and but the other
thing too is I say it's about project
Veritas I think Veritas should release
the raw when they when they do this
stuff like there's a lot of stuff that
Veritas has done it's been very very
important but I'm often like you know it
could quash a lot of these arguments
about deceptive editing if you just say
like we editorialized here's the raw
footage you can see for yourself minus
private information if there's like
addresses or phone numbers and this in
this context I'm really not a fan of
Snippets being released because it's
like okay well what what led up to that
moment like well I said wage slaves we
don't we don't know the context of it
sounds to me like he was potentially
asking a question about well do you do
this you know with all your child he's
like well this is different you're a big
person coming in and where we don't have
to put as much money behind you so we're
concerned that you're gonna have an ad
drop if you're a new person you're
saying you come to the Daily wire and by
this is completely a guess I have no
idea you're coming daily wire and you're
like hey I want to try this thing you
know can you make can you make my name
bigger essentially you're saying like
here are the wages we're going to pay
you you're going to work your ass off
you know what I mean and you have the
the benefit of having the entire daily
wire Network behind you I think he was
probably trying to describe again I have
no idea the different mentality between
getting Talent like Stephen Crowder and
trying to get him in a contract versus
getting Talent that's new and is looking
to come a daily wire because they
basically absorb all the benefit again I
don't know but it is exactly what it is
that's probably what he was saying and
now he excerpted wage slaves as if he
like was uh these pump these slaves that
are working for me I mean it's it's a
colloquialism you know what I mean he's
using that term not seriously but it
allows him to play that extra to make it
sound like this is how the daily wire
treats their employees I mean it's just
horrible stuff that he's doing with
daily wire Jeremy was saying that if a
new person with no audience comes to
daily wire they're basically going to
put them on a contract with a wage and
then they're going to own all the
content that they say they're going to
own and then when the person's done off
the contract they can go continue to be
famous and successful although daily
wire will still own the stuff that they
paid for to get produced while that
person was there and he used the term
wage slave now I'm with you I don't
think the term the words themselves are
that big of a deal no but he wants it to
come across like a big idea like it's a
very big deal because he's relying on
business ignorance he keeps doing this
he keeps relying on business ignorance
and he's appealing and this is literally
a socialist tactic he's appealing to
like you know the Amazon employees who
want to like Stick it to the Man and
then they boycott May pick it because
they're not getting paid you know fifty
thousand dollars an hour and being
treated to ice cream once a week he's
appealing people that he's like okay
think of yourself as an employee not as
a business person right this is a
business person mindset this is what I
get from this conversation obviously I'm
privy to these these talks with Jeremy
and Caleb this is this is who I
negotiate my contracts with and there
have literally been times because I'm a
big girl and I go and I sit with them
where I say there's no way I'm signing
this line you know they move an inch
this way I'm moving inch that way
they're moving into this way you know
and then here we are we we meet here in
the Middle where we all feel like this
is a good contract and nobody's a slave
right because in order to sign a
contract if you fully comprehend it
you're not a slave you're just not a
slave something I think about Jeremy
personally and not too relevant but I
think he enjoys negotiating I think
why are you got to know that going into
it I want to enjoys negotiating I want
to read a Super Chat real quick because
this is an important Point uh idg says
daily wires agenda make profit Crowder's
agenda saving American experiment
exhibit jbp deletes tweets supporting
Crowder exhibit B your poll
I'll tell you what I think I don't
completely disagree with that
um I think the daily wire is a machine I
think the daily wire is a machine that
is not the ideological like system that
I would personally build we do things
very differently here the people who are
here are on salary with no terms like if
you if if pop culture crisis Scott this
is a small company that's how it is when
you work for me I have a company too a
small company where we have seven
employees and it's familial you see
Savannah's downstairs we get to hang out
and do fun things we're a small company
if we grew and we suddenly had 400
employees things have to get a lot more
serious and professional that's true but
I'm I'm and I've talked to Jeremy a lot
about this and so it may just be a great
we're small and then you know he's like
when you get bigger man you're going to
run into these things and I'm like maybe
but here's my thing
I I like the daily wire I think the
daily wire is uh I think Jeremy and uh
you know everybody else involved and
Union James one made the video are
seeking to to make money and and use
that money and and build more and make
more money if the daily wire succeeds
and makes money and then makes more
movies and makes more documentaries that
means we're gonna get more what is a
woman it means we're gonna get more you
know Gina caranos it means Hollywood
will be weakened it means as Hollywood
falls from the hill a machine that
actually at least to some degree shares
our values will be there it may be in
your opinion a cold faceless machine but
at least the cold face faceless machine
is saying meritocracy meritoc I'll be
like okay well well LOL to anyone who
thinks that Stephen Crowder is not doing
this to make money like I mean I just
have to outwardly laugh he's he's the
person in in the sky he's a wolf in
sheep's clothing right he's he's like
I'm not I'm here because I'm I care
about all of you that's why I'm
recording my friend and doing this
crappy thing where I literally could
have just said no I don't like those
terms and then said to everybody I'm
starting my own outfit fair you walk
away all the time you have to go you I
have walked away you know I had an offer
from the blaze it didn't work for me you
know what I don't need to piece apart
the the contract I love those guys I
think Tyler is amazing this is what I'm
saying people need to stop thinking that
he is some knight in shining armor he's
not he's not a knight in shining armor
and if you can't see that watch this
video because I think his acting is
never more apparent even the titles I
didn't want to do this oh really then
why the hell did you record him
what were you doing that for do you
think you're gonna go to Four Points
what do you think you're gonna go to
court because that's the only reason you
record someone you'd be like I don't
trust my ex [ __ ] wife pardon my
language okay I don't trust my ex-wife
so I'm gonna record this phone call for
safety right you record it because
you're nervous if there's going to be a
court here or the police are going to
find out you've got to back up what you
said okay why are you recording your
friend if not because you think it's
going to go to court oh because you
think it's going to go to public and
you're doing it intentionally because
you know you're about to start a war
people please use your common sense I am
not even it's not even because I wear
daily wire it is because he personally
is he's lying and he insulted me and
during his his lion campaign he's still
lying he even said something in this
video where he's like now they're
sending out there no no you took if
you're gonna aim and you're gonna hit
somebody with shrapnel it's gonna be me
you better incorrectly because I don't
like [ __ ] like this okay I have been
quiet I know Steven Crowder two people
like like absolute trash it's a known
thing in the concerned movement ask
anybody that works the place any
questions ever had to show on the place
how Stephen Crowder treats people by the
way you want to talk about contract
negotiations why doesn't somebody reach
out to not get Jared right who used to
be with Stephen Crowder and figure out
why he can't speak why isn't Stephen
Crowder released not gay Jared from his
NDA I don't like [ __ ] like this that's
all I'm saying I don't like it I want
both daily wire and Crowder to succeed
that's what we all wanted who cares
movie yeah something like Lethal Weapon
man me and Steve it's gonna be crazy I
mean Luke Luke's sitting here I don't
know he's straight man it's such a bad
business I'm like this is like well you
know WWE let me explain I personally
just uh you know I I personally don't
care to be honest I want to try and like
I I want to talk about the globalists
I think that what happened Stephen well
first of all why was he recording I
think that's a you know fair question
but we don't doesn't need to be answered
in Texas it's legal to record it's a
one-party consent state so it's like
saying why is he open carrying a gun
because he's planning to shoot someone
like you don't know why he's got a gun
you don't know why he's recording and it
really doesn't matter but but recording
is the action like if he had a tape
recorder when he made the phone call and
didn't record I'd say that argument is
is comparable right for all I know
everyone in Texas is recording every
conversation at every moment and they
have a right to do that and maybe even a
responsibility at this stage of reality
I don't know you know things you say can
be taken out of context if you don't
have the protection of your for yourself
secondly I think what Steven said in
this video that we're probably not going
to watch other through it's pretty long
or what 20 minutes 18 minutes is that
he's not concerned about the money but I
agree with you Candace he did say I
can't do 50 million I need 140 uh
City about 30 million a year what he's
looking for Jeremy said that I think 30
million and then Crowder said he's
counter offered yeah he's like so why'd
you counter offer before you decide the
terms weren't available so after that
after they realized the money that's not
an option we can't do 140. uh Stephen
said then you got to take these uh
demonetization negative penalties out
from like if I violate YouTube's terms
because now you're an arm of big Tech
because you're making me follow
YouTube's terms of service you're
basically a lap dog for YouTube but
Crowder follows their terms of service
too we all do that's the whole point the
first
behind the paywall let's let's not get
let's be responsible let's not get
banned yeah let's talk about the 99
things we can and then the other stuff
we can put on timcast.com so that we can
slide the conversation oh you're
Shilling for big Tech you're what you're
part of VidCon now you're all a part of
VidCon because you're being smart and
you don't want to get banned until we
have a comparable platform to go to
listen to perfect world we would all
wish that we could do I invest all of my
time in trying to support companies and
sometimes they fail and it sucks you
know what I mean like I really believed
in glorified banking it crashed you know
I really believed in the freedom the
freedom phone that didn't work out we
all want an alternative and we
meaningfully want an alternative we just
don't have them we're not there yet as a
conservative movement so while we're not
there yet is our we're just all gonna
what just shoot ourselves in the foot
and be nowhere to prove that we were a
real one right oh it shows that you're a
gangster because you got shot in your
chest nine times if you don't get shot
in your chest nine times you're not a
real gangster like a real effect stupid
fighter against that is to use the
momentum of Silicon Valley against
itself or it for your favor like you
Jitsu it I don't think pushing back is
The Right Use of energy it requires too
much so I you want to use these
platforms to one get the word out about
new platforms and two as hosting because
you can host things behind I mean
obviously they'll get banned hold on
hold on give it to me uh we can check
this pull upon who is the domain for
stop big con was registered on 12 12
2022.
whois.com stop VidCon was registered on
12 12. internet sleuths are going to
catch them Crowder announces he left the
Blaze and asks people to sign up for mug
Club on 12 15 2022. it was all like the
fact like listen I love the internet
slues because this of course is going to
happen and this is the problem is that
Steven has to realize people are smart
Okay people are smart they're going to
figure it out oh so you happened to look
up the to to register Bitcoin yeah let's
confirm that let's stop yeah I got it
right
vidcon.com right now we are 12 12 20 22.
so this was this was registered stop
VidCon was registered before he
announced he was leaving the blaze is
that what it was easy that's so weird he
announced he was leaving The Blaze on
1200 well guys and again Crowder will be
here on Monday he can tell us about all
this I don't want um and then he
recorded his conversation with Jeremy
two months after that I just want to say
like we're we're we're we're in the
middle as per usual Candace was booked a
month and a half ago you know and this
whole drama lights up and then we talked
with Crowder uh we we asked him to come
on and talk about this so I mean there
are so many things I disagree with daily
wire on like so many things this is just
not one of them like this is just
actually someone's being a bad person
and plotting against them that's it
that's all that's all this is right and
that's what I want to say because like I
said before I've been to Hawaii for
three years you've never heard me come
out and defend them but they're in
trouble every other week with a
different host or something that they
said something they haven't said Ben
Shapiro's Under Fire at least once a
week on Twitter people are angry at him
I think it's a show for this but I don't
wait on anything this actually Stephen
Crowder is a bad person I was thinking
what if they just paid Steven 50 million
for his back catalog and then put it on
daily wire exclusive and the only way to
see Steven is to go to daily wire like
that would I don't know 50 million would
be worth it but four-year terms I had a
lawyer you could negotiate or you could
go what if you could go into
dailywire.com and then pay 99 cents on a
Crowder video to watch it for the day
and then Steven gets half the revenue or
something I mean there's so many cool
things we could do I mean things could
do it would require Stephen to just look
at the con the term sheet and then be
like I'd rather do it this way here you
go there you go a conversation he's got
I'm interested to talk to him Stephen
because I think he's got specific
feelings and perspectives on what big
Tech censorship can do to a content
creator that needs to be vocalized for
future contract negotiations I've been
concerned about contracts especially
with like perpetuity Clauses like we own
your likeness forever in every Universe
going forward they'll they'll deep fake
you and make you say things with deep
fakes becoming so realistic they'll own
your face and your name and it's crazy
we need to get perpetuity Clauses for
characters out of for personality out of
contract I think so right now I want to
say this like I don't they otherwise got
a lot of haters and I can certainly
understand not liking the daily wire or
not liking certain personalities I know
people who are like I love Clavin I
don't like Ben Shapiro yeah I know
people who are like I only watch Candace
I won't watch anybody else I think
everyone else is bad and I'm like okay
but like that should say that like we
don't all agree on everything but daily
wire existing is a massive net positive
regardless of whether you like what
they're doing or not like just again
what is a woman was a massive cultural
force and that matters so much we we
talk about culture and the importance of
cultural dominance so much that
documentary reached regular people it
was so big I mean I I regular people I
know were like oh I saw that thing that
was going viral and I'm like hey that's
good do more of that I don't got I don't
got to go work for him Crowders have to
go work for you guys work for I should
say you guys but for Jeremy or anything
like that but and that's why it's so
crappy to paint a broad stroke you know
paint with a broad stroke and say the
daily wire is this because you're
attacking that well that's just nothing
to do with Stephen crowd I have nothing
to do with Stephen Crowder and yet
you're basically making it seem like
we're all plants that we've done
something wrong and that it's that's
deeply upsetting to me it's super
annoying to me I would like to see
people stop saying that company is doing
thing because it's people the people are
doing the thing with the guys of the
company attempting to protect their
their person you know their identity but
like no companies don't do things people
so fair point someone mentioned Crowder
never said the daily wire okay but like
the shmeli schmeyer I mean how many
freaking all of the context clues were
it's like this is the crap the acting of
like I'm not gonna say it was but I'm
gonna make sure you know that it's not
the blaze they have a subscription
service and that there are live ad reads
and that they could afford to put enough
money on a contract when I would have a
conversation does your character have
classes yeah exactly
like literally this is this is such a
ridiculous defense in four seconds you
can discern if this is about daily wire
can't be Fox News they don't have live
ad reads he already told you that it's
not the blaze what does that leave us
left with
didn't you say that you also recognize
the contract Fox News before we got to
it I mean when you say live ad reads a
subscription service you can't be Fox
News because he's already left them and
talks trash with them the whole time and
they don't do live at reads right who
else could it have been just give me
another clue who else would have been
prageru 501c3 not for profit can't have
been them can't can't be give me a
person it could have been so that's what
everybody was saying yeah the daily Wire
yeah so when I never said a name it's
like what do you think about this I
think this was a bad move on a daily
wires part that the contract said if you
get demonetized there will be a fee but
Crowders already demonetized they had I
told you they had these same this is why
I'm saying this was just a conversation
starter they had these same things that
made note literally entirely no sense in
my contract I was it literally I was
like okay is this you guys like Laura
just like copy and paste this from
somebody else's contract like and this
is just a conversation starter like they
just want you to see the number and go
I'm excited and bring your lawyers in
right there were literally things that
were saying like I'm not on Tick Tock
they mentioned my Tick Tock they
mentioned my Snapchat uh and I was like
okay well I'm on any of these things and
I'm never planning on being on them so
we can strike this strike this and and
you know and then you add and then you
say okay this one sounds okay can we
include an extra line here like he kind
of started this idea that my
um my social media channels are
controlled literally they had something
about access to my Twitter check it out
I said I will never ever ever my Twitter
is how I made my entire brand I will
never even share a login to my Twitter
right and then my Instagram same exact
thing and so they created a separate
Instagram which they're allowed to do
which has canason's pod and it has its
own followers and they release stuff
from the podcast I didn't want to sell
my voice you know my social media things
it would have been nice for them to have
access but it's actually better for them
because then they can own that page in
perpetuity Candace Owens podcast because
I'm creating content for them so they
can share clips into perpetuity of what
I have they have paid for right so it's
like that's again just there he's
pretending that there was something
nefarious going on there I got the same
stuff that made no sense you'd say just
like you said this makes no sense
because I'm already demonetized from
YouTube that was my circumstance for
Facebook I was all they had a thing
about demonization for Facebook my
lawyer went back and said Cancer's
already demonetized on Facebook and they
went oh
that's right strike it from the clause
you know for people asking too like yeah
when Crowder comes on I'm gonna let him
again say his piece I'm not you know
like Candace is giving her perspective
working the daily wire and what I went
through the contract negotiation so
there's no way that he can pretend that
there's something missing he didn't go
through them he went through term sheet
don't like 140 million dollars I'm going
on to YouTube I went through the full
five month negotiation so there's
nothing for me to make up here you know
what I mean someone said what if Crowder
and the daily wire planned this for
attention
I love a good conspiracy theory the the
Jeremy the Jeremy response video was
recorded December 3rd oh
I love that I don't know look look again
I'll say it again Crowder's not here to
defend himself you know so you know he's
on YouTube on YouTube how do you really
feel
but uh but look man I'll I'll wrap up
with this and we'll move on to some big
worldly things with like what I got to
make for him Alec Baldwin we got to talk
about Alec Baldwin uh
I I look I I negotiated with the daily
wire on on like here's what happens you
know Jeremy comes on the show and he
says is there is there anything we can
do together and I'm like he's like
because I know you you do a company and
it's not the same as like if we went to
any other person and said come work for
us and I was like there's probably
something we can work out look there's a
lot of stuff I don't know and we're
trying to build this thing we're trying
to do X Y and Z we're trying to do
cultural stuff I know you guys are we
talked we went back and forth and I said
guys I don't think there's anything here
and uh Jeremy was like I think you're
right we went over numbers we know
everything and uh the daily wire said
what if we did this and I said
now it doesn't work it doesn't work for
what we're doing because we want to do
these things and um I'm just going to
come out and say this you know I try to
keep private details but I said I said
Jeremy like I might want to buy a
billboard that says Liz Cheney's a fat
pig you know what I mean like I know
that like the daily and he was and he
started laughing and he went well I
don't know about that and I'm like look
we're we're crazy weirdo Rogues what we
do at Tim cast we we want to be be nuts
and we want to not not crazy crazy but
we want to just be we're we're not the
suits and we're not the corporation
but I think what you guys are making is
good because your version of the
corporation is better than the Disney
version of the corporation but I'm not
the corporation either and I want to
make that very clear and that's what a
noise
there is and then they try to say that
every single host exists on this idea we
disagree all the time like there's
literally it's hard to find a moment
where me and Ben Crossing agree on but
you know what I'm saying and so they
paint this thing of like there is no
like yes the office is very cool I don't
even go into the office there's a
podcast Studio that I go into that is
smaller than this that I that I operate
within so it's just it's very
frustrating because people just don't
understand yes he is running his
business and there's a corporate side of
the daily wire and it's annoying to me
to have to though answer for people that
thinking that that somehow corporatizes
can of zones I've been the exact same
Candace Owens from but at the beginning
of my YouTube days to now but I'm not
trying to imply anything about you or
any of the hosts I mean like they they
it's it's it's a traditional Corporation
it's got personalities of varying
opinions and like us putting a 95-foot
billboard of a rooster and one of the
biggest Times Square Billboards makes no
sense as a business but it makes sense
culturally and it makes sense you know
like we we want to we want to be more
shocking and the daily wire wants to
beat Disney at their game you know we do
to a certain degree but I don't think
you know I look I think maybe in 10
years we can have some kind of network
that'll have a cultural Force that's a
good thing I think the daily wire the
way it's structured actually is set up
to poach the content to poach the the
executives to poach the talent from
these industries of course that makes
you similar in some ways but the output
is corrected you know what I mean that's
why I like the daily wire you know uh
despite not wanting to work for the
daily wire but at the end you know I my
my thing with Jeremy was like I don't
think there's anything we could do
transactionally but there's a lot we can
do culturally for fun yeah and so we're
actually working on some stuff and and
the same thing is true like you know I
talked to Crowder all the time about
Russians all the time but periodically
we talk about culture War issues you
know what needs to be done what we can
do we've talked about the stuff that
Ian's working on with a decentralized
network yeah I got a new company a
relatively new called uh inverted
Technologies and we're building like
basically what patreon attempted to do
or didn't quite get right but that you
you basically upload you download a
packet software packet you load the
application you can upload videos to a
server of your choice when you have your
house you can upload it to rumble and
then you can get yours all these people
can pay 10 bucks a month whatever you
want different tiers of payments to get
access to that content and later as we
build this out it's going to have search
algorithms where you can find other
people other content creators that are
using it and create a network where
everyone owns their own stuff you can't
be banned the idea is like your website
can also have a recommended section of
similar content and you as the website
owner so like let's say we did
timcast.com and we joined this network
you will see in the recommended tab
Stephen Crowder I could go look I don't
want you know he's a competitor and I
like his opinion so I'm going to say on
my website he can't appear but he's not
banned from the network just my personal
site so basically you create a
decentralized that's awesome the idea
would be you launch you you buy your own
server times space for or you make your
own server you set you buy your own
domain and then you download the package
install it on your server and you
instantly have your own patreon that
connects to the network of all the other
people using it for recommendation
reasons because the recommendation is
the real driver of so much of of
everyone's of people if you make good
content and you make a lot of it and it
rises to the top
people will see it and that's the
machine that needs to happen so so but
when YouTube bans you out right you're
gone from the grid when they Shadow ban
you you're gone from the grid this way
you can't do this anyway I've talked
about stuff like that and I want to see
him succeed I uh I I would prefer that
you know the conflict of arguing or
whatever wasn't wasn't happening but
look I talked to Stephen I I genuinely
think believe that he thinks daily wire
is a net negative in the space I don't
think he's doing this for money uh
you're entitled to your opinion I
understand your perspective I've talked
to him about it and he said that you
know these kinds of contracts are I'll
paraphrase my understanding the Old
Guard System created the problems we
whatever we're building has to be new
and it has to be different it has to be
better and it's funny because when I
when I do deals with people I joke that
I'm a communist and that's why they're
getting such good terms when I when I
when I talk with Jeremy boring I'm like
this guy's a businessman who's trying to
make sure no one can stab him in the
back the fact the fact is I think
Stephen Crowder doesn't know this
because he hasn't started a business but
I've been stabbed in the back like 73
times and it sucks every time and I lose
money every time and my my safety is
threatened every time but you know like
I jokingly say I'm a communist so blah
blah not literally but when I'm when I'm
trying to convey by that is I'm still
willing to to over uh extend myself if
it means we're gonna get better people
and that's the system I'm gonna build I
don't fault the daily wire for running
their business The Way businesses run I
like the content the daily wire produces
I just won't be there when they produce
it wonderful you're a free market
capitalist your idea is that if you
believe that you have something better
or you can do something better you
create the something better and I think
take out the old guys I mean like is
that a foreign concept is that has this
become a foreign concept like do do we
have to all be so nasty to me I just
don't get it because I've never since
I've gotten into politics I've never
understood the mentality that you need
to step on someone's head to go where
like oh I just need to step on this
person's head so that I can move
Upstream inside why don't you learn to
swim if you want to go Upstream you know
why don't you want to swim and tread
some water if you want to go Upstream
what is this what for a little bit of oh
I'm going to burn
friendships you keep calling them your
friend I I it doesn't make any sense to
me I'll I'll say my final thought on
this I suppose and then again Crowder
will be here on Monday we'll have a
conversation from his perspective
yo if you're gonna stop anybody I don't
understand why going after the daily
wire is the first Target even if the
daily wire was doing these really awful
contracts like or I should say they're
doing term sheets they're doing
Contracting in ways you don't like I
still think it's like well okay well at
least they made what is a woman let's
focus on Disney and Netflix Netflix has
done a bunch of pedo stuff you know what
I mean like a deadly wire is just not a
concern for me even if I was gonna come
out and be like 49 of the business
dealings of daily wire I don't like but
51 is good then I'd be like I'll take
that one percent and I'll focus on
Netflix doing weird pedo crap yeah but I
actually think the daily wire is much
better than that I just it's not my kind
of business style so you know I hope I
hope Crowder
um just does his thing and succeeds and
and I I think it's simple you know if it
were me and I really did see the daily
wires and net negative I'll put it this
way I mean I talk about Disney all the
time I say I don't expect you to abandon
your Disney subscriptions because they
have Flubber they have movies you know
and love I just hope to build a better
website that eventually produces enough
to where you say I'd rather not have
Disney that that's my strategy but again
guys I'm I'm the milk milk toast Fun
Center I'm the reformer not a
revolutionary I'm not going to come out
smash the ball on the ground and be like
I will stand for nothing I'm going to
sit here and I'm gonna do the math I'm
gonna go daily wire is doing pretty good
you know I might not like that but
that's that's good for us so okay
where's our where's our net problem I'm
I'm much more slow slow paced and
calculate you know calculating than that
I think if the daily wire succeeds we
all succeed and then when Disney's gone
when Netflix is gone when Amazon Prime
is gone assuming and the daily wire is
the only one then we can start saying
daily why are you do better deals with
your with your employees and then the
daily wire is going to be like you know
either do it or don't my take is I'm
glad the conversation is happening
um I think that Jeremy and Stephen have
have seen each other as friends is
important because sometimes easiest to
criticize your friends it's easier to
criticize your friends than people that
might go sue you and don't have any
connection to you at all and and that
daily wire is gaining a lot of steam and
becoming larger and larger so if there
really are problems with the contracts
or the terms off the bat it's a
important that they know that right away
from people with you know large levels
of influence I gotta we definitely gotta
move on because we've got to talk about
Alec Baldwin but two special shout outs
shout out to Hassan the Hun he said on
Twitter I can't get over Stephen Crowder
having his 50 million dollar paid docked
for getting banned if he does too much
racism when he's being hired by the
daily wire to do blackface and every
other flavor of bigotry Hassan's
obviously joking I thought it was a
really really funny tweet I think it's
funny getting hired to do blackface and
then uh Seth Dillon of the Babylon B he
won the day I love Seth I love Seth he
said I didn't want to make this video I
wanted to take a nap but my hand was
forced and then he he makes this video
where he was like the daily wire thought
Stephen Crowder was talking about them
how cute it was really really funny so
shout out I thought those were funny but
let's talk about Alec Baldwin so uh
we're we're gonna revisit the crowded
stuff obviously because we have 50
billion super chats about it and I just
want to let everyone know that YouTube
YouTube deletes the super chats after a
certain amount of money so we can only
go back to like there's a bunch but all
we freedom and the current poll says who
is Right Candace I'm sorry who's right
Crowder or DW 74 say Crowder 26a daily
wire but let's talk about Alec Baldwin
we have this story from Vanity Fair let
me just say at the start of this segment
ladies and gentlemen
I believe I called it and I had people
telling me I was crazy and telling me I
was wrong he's being charged with inval
he's going to be charged with
involuntary manslaughter so is the
armorer another guy the assistant
director I think took a plea bargain
plea deal for negligent uh discharge of
a firearm but let me tell you why I said
I called it there's a very important
part in uh in this story
that I will pull up right here
Vanity Fair says in addition to the
bullet that killed Hutchins well I'm
sorry let me slow down Alec Baldwin as
you know about a year ago was on the set
of a movie called rust he was using a
real gun in the filming aimed at the
cinematographer during filming Paul the
trip pulled the hammer back pulled the
trigger
shooting her in the chest penetrating
her body and hitting another guy in the
shoulder
everybody was arguing whether it was an
accident how could the bullet have
gotten the gun I made the argument that
we had learned
Alec Baldwin was in a dispute I should
say the the execs of the movie
production the higher-ups which includes
elk Baldwin were in dispute with the
crew the crew was threatening to walk
offset there was animosity
Alec Baldwin said he was friends with
her then he said they weren't friends
they didn't know each other he had a
dinner with her sounded like they were
friends or was it negotiations he also
said in an interview that she was very
forceful I can't remember the word he
used and she kept telling him to do
things over and over again it sounded
like he was venting frustrations about
Helena about Helena oh I didn't know
that right and so I said that sounds to
me like motive motive what is it your
crew is threatening to walk offset
costing you money and Helena Hutchins
was doing what cinematographers aren't
supposed to do giving you direction that
he seemed annoyed by my personal opinion
but it's something he expressed
opportunity he had a gun a real gun that
was supposed to be pointed not at a
human being this is against the rules in
any movie Set you never point a gun at a
person no matter what well against the
rules ever always in shooting unless you
unless you're intending to destroy it
right and said he never pulled the
trigger just went off that's impossible
it was a single action revolver Hammer
has to be pulled back trigger has to be
pulled get this
Vanity Fair reports in addition to the
bullet that killed Hutchins
investigators found five additional live
rounds of ammunition mingled among the
movie's props and costumes two loose 45
caliber bolts were discovered on top of
a prop cart a third was in a bandolier
worn by Jensen Ackles a fourth was in a
gun belt worn by Baldwin and a fifth was
found in a box of dummy ammo entirely
possible uh with Gutierrez raised
fingerprints on it they say it's about
someone mistake mistook the live ammo
that was lying around for dummies put
him in the Box Hannah Gutierrez read
pulled the ammo dummy rounds out of the
box didn't realize loaded the gun and
that's what happened entirely possible
but when you factor all these things
together Alec Baldwin had live ammo on
his belt
had the gun pointed it at her and shot
and killed her I don't understand how
anybody would argue that it's more
likely it was an accident when it's like
he was mad at her because the crew
walk-offs potentially
he pointed the gun at her
he shot her and he had live ammo on his
person
so it's like if we were going to ask
someone Occam's razor in the absence of
evidence the solution that makes the
least amount of assumptions tends to be
the correct one how did the gun how did
the bullets get in the gun well you see
what happened was somebody was doing
target practice with the gun and they
left bullets outside one day a crew
member was cleaning up the bullets and
didn't realize there were lives they put
him back in the Box the box was in place
in the cabinet Hannah goodyears not
realizing this grab the box opened it up
pull the balls out put him in the gun
handed it to the A.D who didn't check it
and then headed to Alec Baldwin who
didn't check it and then it went off on
accident or Alec Baldwin didn't like the
lady took a bullet from his own belt
that had bullets in it and shot her
which one is the conspiracy theory and
which one is The Simple Solution sorry
man I just he had a bullet on his belt
okay that's that there were live bullets
found all over the place or like five of
them makes me gives me some reasonable
doubt that maybe he didn't know what was
he wasn't the one that was Ring leading
this that someone went in there and also
I do agree that he didn't like Helena
Hutchins I felt like she was probably
playing the alpha role and he felt
emasculated he's like I'm supposed to
but he treat him like an actor you're
doing what I say get this done we're
doing the shot he's like I'm I'm the
producer I'm in charge so he was like
Bang Bang You're Dead like a potential
child a boy bang Bang Yeah like playing
Cowboys and Indians when he was a little
single Bank Yeah Bang and he's like just
fantasizing about killing her and and it
turned out that someone had loaded his
gun yeah I mean I want to be clear he's
not being tried for murder he's being
tried for manslaughter so that they they
have felt that after examining the
evidence that he did this by accident
and what you're alleging is that maybe
it wasn't so much of an accident and he
actually didn't like her I can't get
over the fact that he pointed the gun at
a human beings it's so important to say
this is not a rule on set this is a rule
always and maybe in New York City where
people don't know anything about guns he
knows things a thing or two about guns
he's been in plenty of movies it's I
mean it doesn't really nothing no I
cannot go over the fact that he did not
know that you should never under any
circumstances unless you are actually
actively trying to kill a human that
walked in you know broke into your homes
attacking your children do you ever
point a gun whether it is loaded or
completely empty at a human being over
literally if you're walking through the
forest and you're about to go on a hunt
you never ever not even in joke and just
ever are supposed to even put that
you're supposed to keep it down at all
times right yeah
that is just a known rule I even Point
imaginary guns down when I'm pretending
to be a guy with a gun yeah there's just
no way that he didn't know that but look
what the media said like the the media
ran to his defense they were they were
saying that is the media right they came
out and they're like there's this
horrible tragic accident and they didn't
bother asking any questions they didn't
bother investigating and if we had a
fair media from the get-go the first
thing that should have happened is there
was fighting on the set Alec Baldwin was
unhappy extremely frustrated he is known
for having a temper he's crazy
people screaming his own daughter causes
like a fat pig and like he's crazy this
man is obviously unhinged he's
completely and utterly unhinged there's
no question but it doesn't matter
actually in Hollywood if you're on
hinged the better right Chrissy Teigen
these people have told you a thousand
times that they are mentally unstable
angry people and yet the media goes he's
funny let's put him on sentence
they propped them up all the time
especially the more crazier that they
are the more the media loves them which
is uh actually a perfect representation
he was also very outspoken against gun
rights activists and now here he is in
this particular situation now I don't
know what happened here we're gonna you
know a lot of people are speculating
let's see what's going to happen through
this court case uh you know obviously if
this happened to a random Joe schmoe
there would have been charges a lot
quicker the fact that there wasn't
charges and the fact that there was so
long so much time in between this is you
know a little fishy but let's see what
happens in the court of law let's see
what happens with the evidence let's see
uh who you know changed their story who
try to cover something up because
there's multiple stories there's
multiple things we don't know what
happened let's wait and see is that are
there more charges or is this the only
charge there's two charges the jury can
choose from one is five years in prison
mandatory whole and I think he gets it
check this out he should get it they say
the first charge is simple involuntary
manslaughter for this to be proved there
must be underlying negligence under New
Mexico law involuntary manslaughter is a
fourth degree felony punishable by up to
18 months in jail in a 5 000 fine it
includes the misdemeanor charge of
negligence use of a firearm seems like a
slap on the wrist the other charge is
involuntary manslaughter in the
commission of a lawful act this charge
requires proof that there was more than
simple negligence involved in the death
it's also a fourth degree felony
punishable bat to 18 months in jail and
a five thousand dollar fine however
this charge includes a firearm
enhancement or added mandatory penalty
because a firearm was involved the
firearm enhancement makes the crime
punishable by a mandatory five years in
jail based on the official narrative
Alec Baldwin should get the mandatory
minimum I'm not a fan of mandatory
minimum minimums and I don't think
Justice will be served necessarily by
sending Alec Baldwin to prison for five
years but based on the laws it stands
I'll tell you why I think he should go
to jail for five years
negligence he was running the show he
was the producer they were using the gun
from the movie to shoot real bullets
they knew there were negligent
discharges on set that is
that that says to me
that they say it requires more than
simple and negligence simple negligence
in my opinion and maybe it's a legal
term so maybe I'm wrong but my opinion
on this is if someone unbeknownst to
Alec Baldwin was using live bullets I'd
say look Alec he should have had
um he should have known where that gun
was at all time at times someone should
have been charged so maybe it's it's not
his fault that you know this happened
but he knew there were negligent
discharges now it's not just simple
negligence now it's him being like
there's something more there you mean
that and I think you're you're saying
that prior to that negligent discharge
there were there were previous negligent
discharges on that so he knew that there
were some mistakes happening and you
would think that after the first mistake
and you go oh great nobody died you
would go let's make sure that we
buttoned this up as I am the producer of
this I need to button this up and again
I can't I just cannot say a thousand
times over if you're trying to present
the case for the prosecution here you're
just going to say how many times has
Alex been in a movie where there have
been guns fired he knows this protocol
he knows that you do not Point aegon
whether it is loaded or not add another
human being not only pointing would be
negligent by the way if he had hit her
and it was a fake round he would be
negligent forget I mean pointing it is
you just you just don't pull the trigger
and point it and then pull the trigger
and the last thing I want to say is that
I think that in terms of the publicity
surrounding this if he had instantly
come out and said this is we are so we
feel so horrified we are so sorry I I'm
just devastated by this I'm just going
away forever like he was he has acted
the part of such arrogance right anytime
anybody asked a question he was angry
how dare you I'm Alec Baldwin like the
way that he has acted after this as if
he's done nothing wrong I mean the first
thing that his the statement he rushes
to make after these charges is total and
complete miscarriage of Justice it is
this is this pompous nature that is that
that is really for me the nail in the
coffin and if I'm on that jury I am
moving to convict this is this is why I
think honestly I don't know if I would
but let me let me say this the reason I
say the five years in prison just to
elaborate he knew there were negligent
discharges now you can argue well but it
was simple negligence that he didn't
correct that mistake that he didn't lock
things down that's what negligence is
yes then he picked the gun up pointed at
her and pulled the trigger right so you
want to talk about simple and negligence
it would be the the the the the the
producer on set not Alec Baldwin who
knew there were discharges and did
nothing to correct that problem he's
responsible oh he got he pleaded he took
a plea bargain for a negligent discharge
of weapon Alec Baldwin knew there were
that was live ammo on set had live on
his person decided to take the gun
knowing this pointed at a woman and
pulled the trigger now come on I would
actually argue murder like passion
homicide lower degree we don't have it
right so at the very least you have to
move to convict on the charges and I
can't see how a jury outside of being an
Alec Baldwin fan does not actually move
to convict him actually I'll I'm gonna
change my what I just said I want to
clarify I think you're right if I was in
the jury and they said you know
mandatory five years in jail I might
nullify that but agree with him being
charged I don't like mandatory minimums
I don't think Justice is served by
sending them to prison for five years
like a year like five years is not going
to change what happened it's not going
to change Alec Baldwin I think it would
change Alec Baldwin well you're right it
would change him I just don't think it
would actually like he's a very angry
erratic unstable man and I think some
time alone in a cell with another big
guy
a nice prison I I think that it's yeah
it's a long enough time that it could
change but a lot of celebrities are just
totally out of touch a lot of them are
ego made a lot of them are just
sociopaths and as soon as this happened
he tried to of course uh put blame on
anyone else but him the first thing he
said is quote someone is responsible but
I know it is not me yeah that's a
horrible thing
that's somebody's mother I mean think
about this it's horrible the emotional
trauma of this guy basically being like
I don't know it's going to prison but we
know it ain't me exactly and then and
then and talking about this he he kind
of alluded that he's the second victim
here out of all of this especially with
some of the statements that he was
making afterwards which is absolutely
just delusional which shows you this
kind of out of touch reality perspective
that a lot of these very powerful people
that are that are empowered by the CD I
would even say satanic entertainment
industry the people that prop up are
some of the worst human beings on the
face of this Earth and sometimes they do
deserve a big reality check-in and I
think this is maybe but they're so far
in the weeds maybe could provide that
speaking of some of the speaking of some
of the worst human beings on the earth
we have this story about Al Gore uh Fox
News says Al Gore mocked as a clown for
Davos rant on rain bombs boiling oceans
and apocalyptic preacher Jimmy filot
reacts to Gore's climate warnings on Fox
and Friends so you guys see this uh when
I mean you know Al Gore basically goes
off saying that like he like it was a
really unhinged rant I mean bro look I
criticized Alex Jones a while a while
several years ago because he went on I I
it was it was an old thing I remember
seeing him on on C-Span or something and
they were like ah it's Alex Jones and
then he immediately just turned to the
camera and goes paper wasn't they're
coming for you and I'm like but I'm like
when I show that to my mom they
immediately just be like this guy's nuts
it's like so you got to take the
opportunity and approach people on their
own terms on his own show I I think he's
great when he when he goes off
Al Gore wanting to to warn people of a
billion climate refugees going the
world's going to end it's going to be
raining bombs the oil the oceans are
going to boil and our homes are going to
sink I'm like okay they they the crazy
man you know calm down and go to sleep
yes talk he's talking what he says is if
there's a billion migrants all of a
sudden that chaos will ensue he's right
but what he's saying is that there will
be a billion migrants so that's the
thing where like I mean what's the
evidence Al you said 20 years ago that
what the world was ending intent like
would that means cops are going to be
melting by yeah and they should be
because we're exiting an ice population
of declines actually gone up since he
made these predictions we're we're still
in an ice age according to I think it's
Utah State people because of the the
flood 13 000 years ago 12 000 when the
meteors impacted North America and this
giant Global flood it it looks like
we're not in a nice age because the ice
melted but we're still in the Ice Age
just having this preliminary amount of
it melted it's all gonna melt it's
supposed to that's why the Earth is
pouring iron into itself through the
river of blood in Antarctica it's
getting ready to fertilize for all this
new fresh water that's coming into it
and we're pulling carbon out of the air
dude we got the graphene Revolution on
the horizon this weird I was like
shaking about too much horse poop on the
ground and there are a lot of solutions
to a lot of the larger ecological and
pollution problems that the world is
dealing with except for the real
solutions are just being pushed away no
one's really talking about those issues
but when it comes to taxing people
regulating people controlling their life
micromanaging every aspect of them
putting them in little eco-friendly
sustainable neighborhoods that you can't
leave and you can only walk and bike
around 15 minutes anywhere in One
Direction when it comes to that yeah
they love that and when it comes to Al
Gore he said in 2009 that the North Pole
would be ice free in the summer of 2013.
I don't thing that happened there buddy
I I I think you were a little bit wrong
this guy's a number this guy's a shill
and it's important to know here he made
330 million dollars off of his green
investment firm ever since losing to
George W bush there's a lot of money in
this grift there's a lot of money in
fear-mongering and he knows this grift
is being exposed so he has to step it up
he has to make this emotional trauma
this larger psyop as crazy as they can
so then Deutsche Bank of America that
were at Davos they were also talking at
the same time during this conference
about you know we need we need to do all
of our business based on carbon
emissions we need to have we need to
reboot capitalism we need a social
credit score based on carbon we need to
make sure everyone is reporting their
own personal carbon this is nothing to
do with the environment this is
everything to do with the subjugation of
the human race and it's not in its plan
as day big money big interest big Power
trying to control you sorry Tim you had
something to say Oh I thought I was
going to say that what the left will
come out and do is they'll say no no no
Al Gore was right 20 years ago when he
said it would be you know ice free by
2013. but then we took action on climate
change and it stopped it from happening
that actually proves Algarve was right
the whole time yeah I mean I just would
like to shout out do not I do not know
this person at all but a book if you
have a child that you want to make aware
of the climate scam which you are
absolutely excited about about the
subjugation of humanity such an easy
book very short read it's called Uh
inconvenient facts and it's written by
Gregory Whitestone and it will wake you
to the fact that the ipcc is just a
corrupt industry every single model they
ever have put out is wrong and they rely
on people not understanding just how old
the Earth is and that it goes through
coldness I mean there was a medieval
warming period followed by a freeze I
mean there's just they're trying to
actually make you think that weather is
something to be fearful of and that
these things don't naturally happen like
forest fires they just naturally happen
they've always happened to the beginning
of time things get hot I just came back
from South Africa while we were there
just temperature hits in Africa the bush
Burns and it's a good thing that it
burns and so people they rely on the the
ignorance of people that are widely
emotional which is why they start this
sort of brainwash when you are in high
school when you are in middle school if
there's always a different scare and
they've been wrong every time so if you
still believe that there are some
element of truth to this just go talk to
people in different generations and tell
them what their big scare was I was
generation global warming we still had
to watch a sad movie of polar bears
drowning and we're told that there were
going to be no polar bears left in fact
polar population has gone up since
inconvenient facts generation before us
they were told the exact opposite that
it was going to be global cooling they
were all going to freeze to death and
then they were like oh got that one
wrong so we're gonna change to global
warming there was the ozone layer the
whole remember the hole in the ozone lay
we're all going to die and then oops
which states that didn't happen there
was acid rain scare where kids were
taught that the oceans were they going
to become so acidic and it was going to
rain from the sky and now it looks like
guys it's promising we're moving on to
rain bombs bundle up and buy a good
umbrella I'm gonna start selling
umbrellas to be fair on the on the ozone
thing we literally did ban the the CFCs
or whatever yeah so the ozone thing
fluorocarbons yeah that was one thing
was like Hey if we keep using these what
is like PC PFC polyfluorocarbon I think
it was all in the deodorant and hair
sprays and then yeah that's a Nuance
argument to understand that but they've
been trying to use this kind of fear
modeling environmental drifts yeah and
it's all about saying some policies we
need the Paris Accord agreement what we
need to fix these things if you're
really scared is more of your money yeah
I was going to say Candace but but you
don't understand if if we give the
government more money the weather will
be gooder yeah that's the basic
principle that they work on because
there are actual things that we should
address when it comes to this climate
when it comes to our environment when it
comes to pollution especially when it
comes from uh the developing World
especially when it comes from China
dumping all of the plastic that Canada
shipped to them there's also a lot of
waste a lot of Destruction because of
war and there's so much hypocrisy at the
world economic Forum not not just them
flying on their private jets with record
emissions record number of jets uh
estimated a thousand one hundred jets
flying in there but but these are the
same individuals that almost in the same
breath are like we need to make sure
that there's not a peace deal with
Ukraine in Russia that's what the U.N
secretary said at Davos this year and in
the same breath they're like but we need
to make sure their environment's good
one of the biggest polluters is of
course the military-industrial complex
and they're cheering it on they're
calling for more war they're trying to
deny every kind of peace deal they're
trying to prolong it and this is the the
worst thing that you could possibly be
that's because they need more money
exactly they need the grip to keep going
without money everything is always about
money and it's the same people
destroying the environment that are
coming to you saying just give us more
money and we'll fix the environment in
reality those Solutions do not work and
create more problems and they fly
private when they talk about it on your
private jet to discuss Ukraine and but
also climate and everything doesn't make
sense when it's put together it doesn't
matter because don't pay attention
because you're supposed to be ignorant
not realize that literally all they want
is money launch a new war and ruin the
climate at the same time they're telling
you that you've got to give them more
money so they can save the climate I
mean it's stunning to me and people that
get behind these initiatives over and
over and over again if you're really
trying to discern what big con is go
find the people that back the military
industrial complex go find the people
that put a little Ukraine flag and told
you that this was your duty to go out
and defend Ukraine to ask no questions
about president zielinski who shut down
that speech I find that to be absolutely
ridiculous I gotta give a shout out to
DC Drano who called Kevin McCarthy
kievan you Carthage
like a pin yeah like a yeah like a pin
and a flag another country's flag I mean
I that to me if you want a marker of
what real big con is go find out who
supports Ukraine and to this day is
still back in Ukraine from day one I was
like this is so obviously military
industrial accomplices makes no sense we
know it's a corrupt country we know that
it washes laundry don't believe me take
it from The New York Times and
Washington Post five years ago and they
highlighted all of his ties to oligarchs
we installed the new government and we
intentionally went to war because they
launder our money and of course Hunter
Biden and President we hopped in
Afghanistan to get everybody home takes
one breath tomorrow we're going to be in
Ukraine I mean it's such obvious
foolishness at this point and that there
are people that are in our movement
pretending that they're whether America
first or they care about you know what's
happening to this country and then they
they support Ukraine like goodbye dude
goodbye how do you support this yeah and
then there's FTX right that was working
with with the world economic Forum yeah
that was working with the bank of
Ukraine that was laundering money not
only to of course a high-level Democrats
but also Republicans all those
politicians right now give back the
people's money I don't understand why
our justice system is not intervening in
the FTX Scandal and saying hey hey Mr
Biden or or Mr uh Crenshaw or Mr whoever
you got this money this money was
actually stolen from clients let's make
sure we give it back why can't we have
that conversation
I don't know if Crenshaw actually got
the money I'm just naming a politician
here so I don't know if it's Liz Cheney
I don't know who it is but there was a
fair amount of money mostly given to
Democrats some to Republicans as well
whoever got that money it was all
through shadowy secret kind of black
money that was given through different
packs and different organizations in
order to kind of launder it specifically
or but but there should be a national
conversation right now being like hey
people were robbed let's give their
money back right now that money is in
the hands of corrupted politicians right
now that we're doing the bidding of
corrupted organizations like FTX that
the world economic Forum endorsed and
then deleted their endorsement of and
tried to hit it away from the internet
as they were promoting this larger Ponzi
scam that stole people's money which is
absolutely insane I would Advocate
letting Sam Beckman free Go free if he
can pay back the 10 billion and I know
he can he let him go free they'll kill
him he's no two you know like he's even
following how many crypto billionaires
he's a drugged up it's just insane I
mean it's insane they're dropping like
flies I covered it on my show I mean the
mysterious death of all these crypto
billiona millionaires what about that
guy who who tweeted like they're they're
running an entire money laundering thing
in Puerto Rico right off of that point
Island 2.0 it's a pedophile ring blah
blah blah and he said and they're going
to kill me four hours later found in the
ocean with full clothes on in his wallet
guess he just went for a swim and ended
up with a bullet in the back of his head
exactly like literally within four hours
death by Suicide I covered it all on my
show literally notice that they're gonna
kill me and it's always the same they
just it's a mysterious drowning and it's
in Puerto Rico he was in the Caribbean
when this happened four hours later
after his last tweet he was dead and
he's one of five I think five or six
hundred billionaires have died in the
last two years under these unbelievably
mysterious circumstances I mean if you
haven't listened to that episode of my
show just to kind of shout myself out
it's actually the most popular episode
that I've that I've released recently
it's called
um the mysterious death of crypto
billionaires it's insane it's insane and
no that is what we should be talking
about there's exactly very dangerous
going on and to your credit way more
important than anything we're talking
about Stephen Crowder
um but that is I mean it's it's around
the world it's everywhere Let's uh let's
let's jump to the story from timcast.com
European commission VP says U.S will
soon impose hate speech laws and it
seemed like a simple statement and and
it's easy to shrug off but you know
going to the bigger context in the
previous segment we're talking about
these evil people their their plans you
got Brian stelter sitting on stage with
these people and they say soon the U.S
will have you know will make hate speech
illegal to them hate speeches opinions
they disagree with hate speech is
disinformation and what's happening is
are these Davos Elite types are
infiltrating big Tech they're
infiltrating elements of the government
and they're imposing these insane rules
not through law
I don't necessarily know if anytime soon
they'll make it illegal they'll make it
impossible said a bad word as everybody
knows your car won't start you can't buy
your your credit card gets turned off
we've already seen it happen how many
people have been debanked bad opinions
no more no more bang for you that's
insane yeah so these are the people who
are meeting and these big event and
these big meetings they're bringing
people like Brian stelter they're
bringing Democrat politicians to sit
down and say they want to control what
you see think and hear yeah Joe manchin
uh was at Davos making arguments against
the Open Press right like what's wrong
what's wrong with the freaking Open
Press Tony Blair was openly talking
about we need a an international vaccine
passport system where we track people's
medical records and allow them to go
places and not places there's another
heart attacks exactly yes uh yeah I
could say a lot more uh I thought that
particularly there was also another
member of a big tech company talking
about how he welcomes the FBI
involvement with uh specifically
cloudflare the CEO of cloudflare came
out and says that he welcomes guidance
from the FBI so so so there's a reason
why the FBI Direct also attends Davos as
well there's there's a reason why they
have a lot of public meetings but they
also have a lot of secret meetings as
well and obviously one hand uh what's
the saying here one hand of washes
washes the other hand here and and
there's a collective interest here of a
lot of these powerful power Brokers
essentially just saying you know you
help me I help you but we're going to
make sure that we come out on top when
we get to essentially take all of
people's Liberties and financial
freedoms away from them
and then that's the game here that's
that's the con here it's it's clear as
day and and they're using these kind of
bland generalized language to to to get
away with it well the reason they get
away with it more importantly though and
this is why the most important
conversation when people say what do we
do to correct it it's the education
battle because the reason is because
there are two we're producing too many
stupid people right who cannot think
through these policies and this is when
you go what is happening on college
campuses why are we having debates about
why are there gender studies Majors this
is a true fact we've never we've never
given out more degrees in America ever
and yet we've never produce Dumber kids
I mean literally Dumber kids I'm talking
about if you sat them down with an IQ
test these kids are actually dumb so how
is that possible that should run in
conflict with one another how are we
giving the most degrees I'm using the
dumbest kids well because it's a concert
effort by the government because they
understand you want to talk about real
slavery slaves I wrote this in my book
oh another free pitch for myself
Blackout
um I wrote this in my book but my thesis
is that what they're basically doing is
modernizing the slave plantation right
you can't now take people into chains
but what was one element of the slave
plan to station well it was that slaves
weren't allowed to learn how to read
these were called slave quotes So what
better way than to make people think
that they're learning how to read but
they're learning nothing they're
learning be scared the plan is going to
be dead in 10 years men can be women
women can be men I have a degree I'm so
smart should they come out super
arrogant convinced that they know
everything and they quite literally if
you drop them off in a forest they'd all
be dead in a week right they literally
know nothing this is all a part of the
big plan right the idea is to produce
dumb people intentionally and think
about this we hear from people like Bill
Gates and a lot of these Davos types
where it's you know we got to reduce
population growth we see a lot of
actions taken that not only reduce
population but also stagnate the economy
think about what happens if you've got
someone who works on a Foundry you know
they're like you know they're making
let's just say let's just say widgets
they're they're smelting metal into
those stuff and then Along Comes a
college grad with a degree in gender
studies
adding a Dei specialist to The Foundry
serves only one purpose it slows the
economic activity it causes internal
conflict which damages their ability to
produce either the United States is
being destroyed for this reason or or
with this tactic or it is inadvertently
being destroyed by the statute this is
what gender this is where gender studies
and black lives matter and the race
initiatives lock arms right oh now you
should hire Talent based on the color of
their skin where's your diversity and
inclusion Department what is that doing
right it's counterintuitive to the free
market it's counterintuitive to
businesses that are growing and becoming
productive is the higher people that
know absolutely nothing but I got to
have this whole department with 10
people that are hired because one's
black one's gay and that means that I'm
a good business and people are losing
money because this is this obviously
this is not a sound economic model and
so there this is much more Machiavellian
people say that the left is stupid oh
they think yeah the people that listen
to the left you may you can maybe
challenge it they're actually not even
stupid they're brainwashed it's not
really their fault like brainwash is
real propaganda to Israel it has real
effects especially when it's taking
place in the classroom where they're
spending six hours a day they're not
even stupid they're brainwashed you
should you should sympathize rather than
call them stupid but the people at the
top that are that are producing this
that are that want this to happen this
is Machiavellian these people are are
insane they're Psychopaths and they know
exactly what they're doing that's what's
something I thought while you were
saying explaining earlier is that what's
more dangerous than having a group of
uneducated people is having a group of
miseducated people that have been
educated for nefarious purposes because
it's harder to untrain the brain than it
is to give it something new especially
when you give it a degree because when
you give it a degree what you're giving
them is they they think they're smart oh
my gosh the number one thing that the
left says to me is well you didn't even
graduate college like the that's that's
there okay so let me get this straight
I'm I'm doing better than you I have a
larger audience you but you have a
little paper degree so they go out and
those people then get really angry
because they try that degree in a free
market Society they have no success and
they become bitter angry resentful
perfect little leftist that will March
in the street talking about how this
entire system needs to be burned to the
ground because how do they not become
successful when they have a degree you
know you know I like to say when because
because they lose to me all the time
they'll tweet like yeah see this proves
Tim's a high school dropout or don't
listen to music High School Dropout did
you drop out of high school yeah oh wow
and my response is your high school
diploma in five and five bucks will get
you a cup of coffee it should be three
dollars but thanks to the way you voted
it's now five dollars
but it's the number one thing it gives
them this inflated ego like they
actually think even though their entire
life tells them their remarkable failure
but I have a degree it's like my guy oh
okay they're yeah they'll be humble you
know what I mean like look I don't I
don't expect everybody in the world to
be a millionaire I don't expect
everybody to have a six figure salary if
you're somebody who works an honest job
and says you know look I did everything
they told me to do if someone came to me
and said look man I went to college I
got my degree I worked really hard and I
make 35 000
000 a year as an administrative
assistant I'd be like you know look man
we'll I'll try and give you some advice
and help you out out you know just be
humble like you know we're trying we're
trying to help you out it's not it's
it's I don't think it's society's fault
I'm sorry I don't think it's the
individual's fault that they were lied
to by the machine and tricking them into
getting a student loan debts and all
that stuff but if you come out and
you're like I'm so much smarter than you
because I finished high school I make
thirty thousand dollars a year I'll be
like my guy
please
right yes
yes hey what the Rockefeller family did
when it came to shaping modern education
was was pretty smart was pretty billion
they made a lot of good Factory workers
that regurgitate and repeat everything
they're told to repeat they follow all
their orders they make sure that they
get the job done for the boss and what
what else did you think would bring us
the big farmer if you're going to talk
about Rockefeller you can you can you
have to mention big Pharma right you
literally have doctors that are
graduating Harvard right now I cover
this on my podcast this week they are
graduating Harvard and they believe that
children are born with the ability to
pick their gender I mean like they're
talking about infants right now I call
this on my show infants they believe
have within them possessed within them
the knowledge to know that they're in
the wrong body right I have an infant
an infant knows absolutely nothing we
know but this is the people now are
convinced that they are brighter than
you because they're a doctor and they
became a doctor because they graduated
from Harvard you I'm like you I know you
went to Universe you have to go to
university to be that dumb nowadays it's
you have to spend four years in school
to be this stupid I can't I can't
remember this but my mom tells people
that when I was little when asked what I
wanted to be when I grew up I would say
a pumpkin
because like being a little kid who
doesn't understand concepts of like
reality jobs or otherwise I I was like I
don't remember saying that but I mean it
sounds like something a three-year-old
would say is that why you started this
company I wanted to be a pumpkin it's
research and development well people
don't get there in the in the basement
identify as a pumpkin
oh you're right we get tattoos you were
so smart you were so smart you were so
ahead of your time we've got a genetics
lab in the basement and all of the all
of your all of your super chats all of
your Tim cast membership go into DNA
manipulation to convert human cells into
pumpkins pumpkin human chimeras the
noise keeps me up at night I just tell
myself they're chicken no but like a
little kid doesn't know anything I'm
joking by the way they believe an infant
no I mean it's it's crazy it is crazy
what's happening are they being told
that at Harvard while they're learning
it in a book that's a problem if you
want to trick a person like that is a
student just put an academic put it in a
book literally it's incredible to me
this goes to the Sam Harris thing I
don't know if you guys are friends with
them please go back and find Sam Harris
and in our com and our little debate on
Twitter the things that he called me
because you know why because Sam Harris
has a degree and then it was literally
the funniest conversation ever Dave
Rubin tried to like be like oh two
people that I'm friends with like I
don't want them fighting you guys should
get on the phone like this is to Dave
rubin's credit by the way and he gives
their parents my number he calls him
this is the day that they announced that
like Cove it's happening and things are
going to shut down I'm in Texas I'm
about to go to an event and he sounds
like he's an effing bunker like he
sounded like a crazy person he's like
you don't understand this thing's gonna
get really bad and like I spoke to my
doctors and you know I know people I
know doctors that are in Italy in you
know in in two weeks there's going to be
gurneys in the streets nobody's gonna be
able to go anywhere Candace please you
have to be responsible with your
platform you need to encourage people to
get inside where I mean he literally
talk about a conversation I should have
recorded right because this is like it
was stunning he went crazy and then and
then he went on other podcasts and he
called me I mean a categorical imbecile
all these things you know why because he
went and he got a degree and he called
his doctor friends and his doctor
friends all said they understood this
thing because they were reading what was
in a book and now they were reading
studies it's like all you have to do to
trick an academic is to put it in a book
and it becomes magically real and they
suspend their ability to think
critically because that's what too much
schooling does it's suspend your ability
to think critically because your job in
these at these University campuses is to
remember information and not to to
regurgitate information it's not to
think quickly and go wait a second let's
just defies common sense right you know
they just go oh but it's right here
right here it's a passage but but more
importantly it's also to follow the
hierarchy so if there's a boss if
there's someone paying you if there's
like a Bill Gates creating something
like the bill chill in the scientific
Community you cannot criticize that
because if you do you're going to get
your funding cut from you and people
don't understand especially when it
comes to American history there have
been so many Horrors in American history
that have been done through doctors
whether it was the Tuskegee experiments
the MK Ultra experiments Operation Sea
spray that's another one
which became the MMR vaccine the secret
government
poisoning of of San Francisco residents
with a plutonium oh yeah there's there's
also the forced sterilization that has
happened all throughout this country uh
since the 1900s all the way up to 2010
the Florida California right now that
makes no effing sense scientifically the
worst Horrors that Humanity faced were
rubber stamped by doctors that were
following orders and just doing what
they were told hey tell me real quick
what's the operation sea spray Operation
Sea spray is when the US government was
was doing a bioweapons experiment on San
Francisco in the 1950s was that when
they were spraying or something on
people Secret in which
serratia
Mark hesenz and basilius
globigi bacteria were sprayed over San
Francisco Bay area in California to
determine how vulnerable a city like San
Francisco may be to buy a weapon exactly
it was a 1950 1950 that's like right on
that military industrial complex this is
all the stuff that we know about so this
is what the what the secret agencies
with the federal government government
was doing decades and decades ago
there's probably still a bunch of stuff
that we don't know about today but the
sterilization aspect is one of the
biggest because it continued all the way
up to up to 2010 when Californian women
prisoners without their uh knowledge
were being sterilized by the government
so this has been happening for a very
long time there's a lot of eugenicists
out there there's a lot of people that
believe that there's too many people in
this world and they have created so many
Horrors that need to be addressed and
rectified and this is public knowledge
imagine what's secret do you guys know
about the humanzy no the Chip sounds
like a human chimpanzee that's right so
it's you know if you read about it
they'll tell you it's hypothesized
there's urban legends about it
but I'm sorry man if you think that the
various governments of the world did not
try to create chimeric human hybrids and
other weird nonsense then you're naive
yeah now Alex Jones coming out and
saying they're making cow people and
stuff maybe a stretch too far but
there's there's an old story about
apparently apparently the urban legend
is that and maybe it's history in the
Soviet Union
they were uh taking human women and
inseminating them with chimp semen yes
because you can't do it the other way
around because chimps are too small a
female chimp can't carry a human baby
it's too big but a human female can
carry a human Z because it's smaller and
so they were like offering women money
or just forcefully doing this you think
the United States isn't doing anything
like that they're definitely doing this
is like funding it and then having it
done in China what do you think I mean
the coveted like no I guess we'll wait
until we're behind us
total big con move but like a lot I want
to say about the vaccine and by the way
I said a lot of stuff at the back seen
publicly on my show I mean I you guys
know I do not fax my children yeah I am
like I think maybe the only vocally
person that says proudly that I am
anti-backs actually that little like
smear of Cam oh you anti-back so I'm
like yes put it on my check I get in a
badge form like thank you I had to help
these children in the entire world I was
injured by a vaccine you're not going to
Gaslight me against an injury and I
suffered everything you just said ditto
oh well we actually we actually do have
a story we can talk about the members
only show that Luke was bringing up
which will be really interesting and
there's a lot more we can add yeah about
you know uh bump stock Donnie there but
that's a separate that's a separate
subject there but but
um again human experimentation has been
done by so many high-level government
officials and what they're doing right
now I can't we can't even imagine and
it's not just being done in Ukraine with
uh the specific gain of function
research they're doing there it's not
just being done in China it's being done
domestically there's a lot of things
that again we could get into the weeds
we could go down the rabbit hole
especially when it comes to Lyme disease
agent orange gay bombs exactly
you mentioned it was led to the MMR yeah
I mean the DDT scan people if you want
to really start learning about vaccines
it all begins people believing that
polio was eradicated and LOL if your
starting level is you think that polio
was eradicated there's so much that
people have to understand about vaccines
I am now of a very formed opinion that I
believe that there is a true government
war on fertility they want to own the
means of fertility and this is big this
is happening in the classroom with
convincing women when we're 13 to get on
birth control pills and telling you
there's no effect there's no effect in
me taking hormones every single day
that's crazy really there's going to be
no effect to me taking hormone pills
every how stupid I mean again common
sense but I read it I read it a book
there's a sterilization program being
run right now against the people of this
world and many people don't even realize
it and I just want to add to just just
to stop and think about how crazy it is
that we Mass hormonally medicate females
in this country and mass and there there
are people I know that that uh women who
are said never touched it I had a bad
feeling about it in my gut when I was 13
and every time I went to the doctor like
if I was like oh my head hurts to be
like birth control yeah I was like oh
like my belly hurts like birth control
I'm like oh I have a cramp they're like
birth control I'm like okay well this
can't be like an all-catch pill why are
you trying to try to get me on birth
control pill and I just thank God I had
that spiritual Assurance I was like this
is weird this is weird it is weird it
destroys women for the rest of their
lives
let's go to super chats and uh read do
it well I want to read just one very
important Super Chat right away from
Daniel a he said ironic Crowder was on
Arthur and now he's fighting with DW I I
posted that on Twitter yesterday
I did not miss that because I was a huge
by the way I was a huge Arthur family
this is why this is the biggest that's
why I'm really sad about this dude I
watched Arthur up until they canceled it
I loved it not really well I mean I'd
watch if it was on right now I'd just
jump off and just watch it it's a great
show
it's the only reason I knew what
Aardvark was let's be let's be honest I
liked her yeah so he has an aardvark
confirmed okay kind of weird his face
isn't really shaped like that no it's
not all right so we got a whole bunch of
super chats to read smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends we're gonna
read your super chats
um the end result of that poll was
massive there were about fifty thousand
it was like 45 000 votes and I think it
was 74 in favor of Stephen Crowder so
wait what poll I did a poll for the
audience who do you think is right when
uh when we started the show okay Crowder
with the daily wire and how long does it
run for we ran it until I think 9 10.
okay and it had about 45 000 votes 74
said Crowder it started a little higher
and started to shift down a little bit
some people said daily wire Bots were
attacking no I just think well powder
one then daily power bots clearly
weren't attacking yeah it's just like
not everything is a conspiracy theory
guys all right let's read let's read
let's read uh Buddha brother says from
these comments I've decided the right
has now swung too far no one's actually
thinking everyone sees everything they
don't like as evil left Matrix Crowder's
acting like a child
everything I just said now everything is
a conspiracy and that's what's so
frustrating to me is
heard something that was just a regular
contract negotiation into this huge
conspiracy that there's like some
Boogeyman and there are plenty of things
you can pick apart with daily wire for
this is just not one of them this is
just how business goes you know Megan
Cole says why do people always assume
the worst of each other it is possible
to mess up a situation and have good
intentions mistakes or differences of
opinions as uh are far off from
malicious intent well said I think
Crowder sees malicious intent
I think the daily wire or is he the
malicious intent well they did uh it
looks like from what Jeremy was saying
or in your opinion it's that Crowder is
trying to personally benefit from the
controversy and then Crowder's opinion
makes it seem like he's ideologically
opposed to the way that the daily wire
and probably and he didn't say daily
wire specifically at first I do believe
Fox I think Fox is probably like not a
good company to contract with we talked
about it Fox foxcast hosts can't come on
this show
but whatever man look nobody owes me
anything if they don't want to come on
the show I don't really care
all right let's uh let's see where we're
at what's trending on Twitter
what is uh Candace
Candice followed by Stephen Crowder the
top trends are Candace and is trending
in news and entertainment Stephen crowdy
and the third trend is brawny wait what
are you like seriously yeah so let's see
trending
uh
so here's what I'm seeing for you Crosby
Steph Tatum Crowder number four
is number two in news for me yep
would you look at that
we're all right let's see I asked my I
asked my followers what my last thing
was what do you think about him sharing
the phone call I I love it I just like
we should be bringing the super chats
they're paying I mean that's probably
better frustrating those you know you
know why this is trending so much though
it's because the the woke left
the the the corporate left establishment
like Daily Beast and rolling stone are
writing huge articles they're they're
like sharks smelling blood in the water
and they're like you know quick attack
attack the right underneath my question
of what is everyone's thoughts about
Stephen crowd recording his conversation
Mike sonovich says Jeremy said wage
slave I'm literally shaking at having to
hear a term that I and all of my
co-workers called ourselves went on a
guaranteed salary that arrived like
clockwork without any of our own assets
at risk Viva fry hope I'm saying that
right I love him by the way he's a great
videos said I don't know who can think
surreptitiously recording a conversation
among purported friends can possibly
look good that's my point secretly
recording conversations in general looks
bad on its face it requires a very
serious justification above and beyond
unsatisfactory negotiations that like
this one it was a lot of this is common
sense Bryson says it makes him look
prepared he recorded the conversation
after registering stop vidcon.com Yes
like it's like I just don't understand
to me it's like
so obvious like you may be a best friend
but if you are sitting across table for
me in a contract no negotiation you're
an adversary I mean all of my con my
comments I'm not seeing that people are
thinking that this is an okay thing for
Steven to have done so that's
interesting that there's a discrepancy
collect the misfit says what's the over
under Crowder cancels his Monday
appearance after seeing this show zero
this recorded conversation was
definitely a bridge too far it's like
that's where people should focus on the
recorded conversation and the fact that
he did do a counted offer and again I
will not defend daily wire in every
capacity I I respect a wire I have a
good working relationship I do not
consider Jeremy boring or Caleb to be my
friends but they have been Fair
negotiations they have acted at the part
of businessmen and if you do business
you should expect that this is how it
goes is what I'm saying and it's also an
indication that they'll go to bat for
you as a contractor employee when
they're negotiating on your behalf as
daily wire if that ever comes up yeah
you know Jeremy's a good negotiator I
mean it's hard you know
it's it's freaking business you know
what I mean I personally defend Steven's
right to record with that's on anyone
it's a one-party consent State I like it
all right
I I I don't see uh if Crowder cancels
FBI it's because he's a busy guy and not
because of not because he's right UPS
okay uh oh so uh here we go Jay yeah
says so fun to watch the left and right
eat themselves it's all crumbling I need
more Ian who surprisingly has the most
level head thank you sir thank you just
keep treading water eventually you'll be
the only one left I guess I was saying
it'd be funny if we started the show and
had Luke wearing a judge's robe and like
a wig with a gavel I like that your case
and then I'll determine who I like Luke
he's on anti-team anti-vax so we're just
chilling over here yeah I don't know if
you've seen those yet Candace but these
are chakra vibrators have you no
you ding it and then you
you put it on your body and they're
different different chakras each one is
for a different chakra all right let me
read some more AJ says Tim this is all
theater between Jeremy and credit to
swing the news cycle they are both
faking like WWE pay Luke the 50 million
dollars yeah where's my 50 million
volunteer here WWE because I love it
here and it's really fun to be a part of
these conversations oh oh yeah well
speaking of that David Frederick says
Luke your t-shirt company completely
scammed me one of my shirts was never
delivered one was delivered with holes
in it I have reached out to you in the
company and have had no help I highly do
not believe that I actually messaged my
team because I saw that I read every
single chat that happens uh during these
conversations and here's my uh work chat
and I and I and I took a picture of it
and I'm like hey uh let's try to fix
this right away my team's like we don't
know anyone under that name we just
checked all of our records we don't have
that but if there is a problem we always
fix it I I strive on having the best
customer service and you could email us
info we are change.org and David
Fredericks um if that's not the name you
went by when you bought the t-shirts we
will fix it right away uh because uh
yeah I mean that that's what we do here
and if there's a problem we'll you know
that's it doesn't sound like something
that would happen with us but if it did
we'll fix it right away Josh Branson
says you you going to give Crowder 30
minutes to personally insult people like
Candace is he's been doing it on his own
on his own platform so does he need more
than 30 minutes I mean is
in for Crowder if you're looking for
personal insults I suggest you look at
the video that he made which implied
that all of the daily wire hosts were
sellouts so there you go I'll be
watching funnily enough Crowder probably
wouldn't have used it if not for Candace
here
I'll just say when Crowder comes on he's
going to be allowed to say exactly what
he wants to say about it the same as
Candace is allowed to talk about what
her opinion is
you know how do people expect me not to
be offended when he like go if you now
that you've seen Jeremy's video go back
and re-watch Crowder's video and just
realize you will see it how many times
he lied and intentionally omitted
certain truths that would have made the
daily wire look better and made the host
look better and the slight little Jabs
at the host of like you might be
noticing that they're kind of dumbing
you know like being sanitizing their
opinions like these were all Jabs at me
okay so let's and me and all there's
only a few hosts the daily wire there's
only a few of us right so when you do
something like this and you kind of just
say um it's a lot of other people you're
taking attacks on me as well and I have
a right to defend myself Always There
You Go Cody kopka says why did Jordan
Peterson delete his tweet in support of
crowder I I I was actually curious about
that I saw people like tweeting about it
but I wasn't aware of it so do you I'll
give you I'll give you my thoughts yeah
uh Jordan Peterson probably tweeted out
the video from Steven Crowder and then
some of the daily wire probably said to
him like Hey you know that's about us
right and he was like oh I didn't
realize and they're like yeah and he was
like I'll take it down yeah that
probably believes is insane opinion I'm
sure there's bigger conspiracies that we
can create for the internet so let's
make one up just just so people
understand that's way too safe that's
way too common to take for the internet
but but so people are probably thinking
they're like is he really in a
relationship no but here's what's going
to happen people are going to think that
like Jordan Peterson tweeted it out then
Jeremy went to him and said you better
take that tweet down or else we're gonna
take all your money and then Jordan was
like please please don't take my money
mask off me but not yet now we're warm
enough I need my fancy socks
no yeah like Jordan Peterson's locked in
like a small white white room with a
lobster like he's petting it and then
Jeremy walks in and grabs the lobster
and he's like if you want [ __ ]
he's like no my lobster no no it's just
having worked for like fusion and vice
people who work at companies don't need
to be told what to do
no one no one needs to go to someone at
fusion and be like hey you know we're
we're demanding you cover the story and
say it this way
the people they hire they they'll go to
you and be like oh hey um we saw your
tweet this morning don't you feel like
it's kind of racist and they'll go oh
I'm sorry about they'll take it down you
don't got to ask them they only hire the
people who are already in line and
willing to to cooperate in this way and
like cohesively function like that so I
think Jordan Peterson was probably like
oh I didn't realize delete I didn't
think twice like I don't want to be
involved in this and yeah goodbye yeah
yep but that's again let's go back to
the Lobster Theory and he's locked in
the basement and Jeremy and him are
dating it's like well it's like that
scene from Iron Man too you know when
they walk in and take his parent from
him and put in the bag and he's like I
just took your stuff how does it feel
like they take his Lobster and put it in
a bag and Jordan Peterson's sitting
there
make the tweet
all right all right where we at
Dorian Marius gray says I'm with Luke
who cares about all this bickering
between conservative media personalities
we got globalists trying to kill us
every day with their policies and making
a new world order there's a eugenicist
depopulation program happening right now
okay Crowder we got better things to
talk about that's just my two cents here
people listen I agree
I like the conversation about the
contracts that's super important it's
been that needs to change
um
Dixie tailgate says Candace and Emily
campagno should start their own show
called Hot fast talking conservative
chicks dude when I get fired up I speak
so fast and I consciously try to slow it
down but when I get upset I'm just
did it or is it always like that or did
it get more over the years oh I would
say that it's a family trait yeah but
I've gotten better at it and I slow it
down when I'm being intentional but then
when I'm fired up
do you listen that fast too
I listen extremely fast I do I see I
intentionally pretend I didn't answer
your question very slowly that was
intentional tried really hard there guys
deep breathing breathing
also keep your forehead relaxed thank
you whatever this does yes Alex D he
says Candace is a liar Crowder requested
30 million dollars a year for four years
minus production costs not 140 million
dollars per year as she claimed when I'm
okay I'm sorry if I got the math wrong I
get the most important part of the
30-minutes here times how many years
he's saying I think it was 20 over four
years 30 million years but I said 140 I
should have said 120. I would like to
apologize for the LIE there's probably a
big conspiracy as to why I lied not just
that I made a simple mathematical error
and your big conspiracy would be right
the point is is that he made a counter
offer so he was not outraged by the
terms I'm just I'm I'm so annoyed by the
people who are like quote tweeting
people like will summer he's like a
Daily Beast writer come on that guy's a
total scumbag and he's and he's taken
cut her out of context I'm like you
don't have to like or agree with Crowder
but what really pisses me off is I'm
seeing tons of people even conservatives
and and moderates and centrists
retweeting a guy who makes things up and
then making fun of crowd and I'm like no
no no disagree with Crowder on the
merits don't listen to a guy who's lying
about what Crowder said don't promote
will somner you know what I mean like at
all ever under any circumstances you see
you know it's bad when when your
criticizing Crowder but actually
defending it from the lies of will
summer yeah I mean it's Wilson I mean
like he's he's a total Dirtbag and so
while I think what Stephen Carter did is
wrong and it's a dirtbag move it doesn't
help us by promoting another Dirtbag yep
GBP says Hassan ABI is a self-admitted
Marxist that's right and the Tweet was
still funny
it was funny
it's funny when like I see people on the
right take a joke tweet from vosh or
Hassan seriously and I'm like come on
guys like vosh is not seriously
advocating for eating people yeah you
know what I mean like he'll make a weird
joke or whatever and then people will be
like and then you retweet it and it's
like retweet suddenly become
endorsements and people are right so act
like people on the left and it's like
all right dude chill like chill and
you're not really communist right just
to be clear right yeah I say federali
says I'm glad this conversation is
happening as well but I also agree that
I just want Luke to talk about the
globalists for a while thank you thank
you very much there's a war on for your
balls testosterone and sperm levels are
declining to record levels Humanity will
face a crisis of civilizations that will
no no
freaking bounds we are in deep trouble
unless we wake up right now people I'm
just sitting here talking about business
relationships it looks like they're
coming for your balls they are literally
people listen learn to take your balls
read that comment suggestion box get
something here so that your guests can
read too
oh I mean
I don't have the best eyesight the new
studio we're gonna have um
monitors for everybody yeah
so that the the issue is we just you
know we learned and so now we're gonna
have actually a little modules in the
table that pop open you can plug your
laptop into and like yeah see what
everybody's saying so I could fire
answer anything that popped up there's
just so much so you know I can only read
so much I try to find I try to find good
ones I don't want I don't yeah you know
it makes sense of course you can't you
can't answer but but all of them are
basically saying I hate Candace she's
ugly yeah why isn't she backs for kids
do you get them any vaccines zero
percent just healthy human beings out
the way they're born Josh vicker says
Candace said Crowder called Jeremy two
months after registering the stop VidCon
on 12 12 22. she's using personal
attacks that she condemns others for
wait that that's an interesting point I
wouldn't call that a personal attack
personal attack it's a timeline yeah if
Crowder registered stop VidCon on
December 12th but then called Jeremy
unlike January December 22nd actually no
10 days later 22nd no it was it was
still the 12th do you want to you want
to play I think it was the 12th yeah
okay so that I misread it that's my fall
well that's funny that's right and then
the 15th was when he made the joint mug
Club thing right okay so we checked the
who is and then I guess he called Jeremy
a week ago a week ago and then recorded
a conversation so it it's it's nefarious
a week ago and then he recorded the
conversation so everyone can put the
context clues together and solve it so
he had intended to launch that big con
and then he decided to call Jeremy and
record maybe the super chatter was
saying you said it was two months after
but it was one month after guys clearly
either way
I've been got yeah either way it was it
was before
Dale Barra says Crowder is in the wrong
however I think JB should have accepted
that they missed on demonetization later
with Crowder questioning the DW's
conservative values doesn't know
contractor relationships or how much DW
did did in the culture War
I just don't understand why if you get
if you hire me to work for you and I get
completely demonetized and I can no
longer produce any content like you just
I should just keep paying you because
you're a friend well no no I can
actually simplify this the daily wire
wasn't trying to hire Crowder the daily
wire was trying to license content I
think the daily wire could have made the
contract sound like this Luke I will do
a contract with you to license 192
YouTube videos
I'm not signing no contracts but here's
my point where's my toilet paper
the daily wire could have just said we
will license 192 episodes of the lottery
show to appear on Apple Facebook Spotify
and YouTube if you miss one of these
episodes for any reason we will you know
doc you on the fee that can measure it
to the episode lost
then basically if Crowder got banned
he'd he'd you know daily wire would be
like hey Crowder um we noticed that
you're short three episodes from the
contract and you say well I'm banned
from YouTube I'm like okay well
then you're in breach of contract
which is what they did right they
actually it's even more favorable
because they said we're only going to
dock you a percentage of the contract so
you can still get paid which is the
theory is saying they should have
dropped him and said now you get zero
percent which is actually a more
aggressive contract well so the issue is
the daily wire the way they structured
the licensing agreement they set
separate it right they they could have
just said zero percent if you get docked
if I tell you I am buying 10 YouTube
videos and then you get banned from
YouTube you are unable to complete the
terms of contract I pay you nothing
that's work those are worse I know
that's my point that this is literally
we're all agreeing actually they were
being nicer because they said we're only
going to dock you 20 of the fee I'm like
please guys if I misquoted it please you
got my point is that they said 20 of the
fee if you get banned from YouTube so
they were actually being nicer in those
circumstances because the norfolks don't
say you get banned from YouTube sorry go
kick rocks that's what you're saying
that that would make sense you can no
longer perform but it's because they
were hiring Crowder and that's why what
do you mean they weren't hiring him so
he's not as an employee an employee yeah
but the point is is that it's it's the
same it's the same concept no no no this
is important it's important distinction
okay yeah I'm not comprehending what
you're saying then daily wire is
licensing the lottery show right that
Crowder has to produce and deliver same
for me if he can't deliver they reduces
pay right if they hired him directly
then the daily wire assumes those risks
because they run the whole thing there's
a difference between a license fee I'm a
licensed fee that's what I'm trying
exactly it's the same thing but it
wouldn't make sense in a license fee if
you can't make the content they should
say kick rocks right right the
difference that what I'm saying is if
Crowder wanted the daily wire to assume
100 of the risk he needs to be an
employee oh oh you're that I was missing
that piece you're saying he should have
become an employee that even in that
circumstance if you are an employee and
your job is to create content
if you can't create the content but as
an employee that's on the business okay
cool but he didn't want to be an
employee he didn't even want to come
into the studio make his content he
wanted to own all the stuff and make his
stuff out so I mean this is what he
didn't he didn't want that option right
it's an important distinction I think
people need to understand the daily wire
wasn't hiring Crowder as an employee
they were licensing the show yeah which
is how it is for me their life their
licensing my my content so it makes
sense that if I can't make my content
it's done like and actually it's
favorable to say like actually we're not
going to be done with you we're still
going to pay you some money and we're
going to try to replace this in the time
and come up with something behind the
pay well whatever and we're gonna duck
at 20 that's actually which is why when
uh DC Drano is here I keep calling me
straight Rogan when Rogan was here he
was like I don't know this actually
seems pretty okay you know this well at
least I'm not saying you're completely
gone this is kind of nice you know
here's the challenge my advice to people
would be not to sign a contract like
that I mean especially if your Crowder
Crowders big but then you gotta admit
Brett Cooper is Big why would you not
sign a contract like that I guess I'm
trying to get to the bottom of why would
you not sign a contract that says that
if you cannot if you are banned
obviously we CA we can't make money off
of you why would you say that this is
not a good contract I wouldn't I would
recommend everybody do their own thing
yeah and I think that's kind of the
conclusion that they came to right is
that I want to do this you want to do
that like you had the same conversation
with DW I've had conversations with
pretty much everyone in the conservative
movement where I went okay I this
doesn't really work for me it doesn't
work for me and you walk away because
you have different ideas you know
Stephen Stephen thinks she's a Tom Brady
I mean that's the truth with and and he
thinks I'm too big for this that's fine
if Tom Brady wants to orchestrate a
contract to go back to the Patriots and
negotiations fall apart is he really
supposed to to try to burn down the
Patriot organization or to say that we
just couldn't come to an agreement and
that's called like I said being a big
boy like it it just didn't work out
button puncher says ten dollars says
Crowder bails on Monday I don't think
he's gonna bail I don't think so I think
he's gonna I've talked to him quite a
bit I think he should drop the whole
recording by the way
because it's just like he did part of
the contract and then the part that made
daily wire look bad and didn't show the
other it's like why don't you drop I
have no idea that phone call says I'm
understanding from Jeremy that it was
like a pleasant friendly conversation
about Christmas right and then he
shifted the conversation made himself
telling a hero drop it drop a
conversation stop giving us peace peace
meal information let let transparency
win the day right
daylight is the best disinfectant as
long as Jeremy and Stephen are both into
it I 100 agree I would like to I would
like them to decide it together
pieces of it yes I think Jeremy
mentioned that he wouldn't mind if it
was public I like Crowder I think
Crowder's been screwed over multiple
times by by contracts and and I think if
you look at his career and then he I'm
imagining he was like he leaves the
Blaze and then he looks at these
contracts and he's like this is the same
thing everywhere I don't like this
I mean start your own business it's like
oh I'm an employee at Chipotle every
time I have this these contracts
anything I've worked at Chipotle and
I've worked at Subway and I just don't
like the fact that I have when I when I
sign my employment contract that I get
paid around this I think I should be
paid this sounds like it's time to start
your own business sir rank says Brett
Cooper responding now on Instagram nice
Brett Cooper in the middle so here's an
important Point look if someone asked me
I've had people come to me because
rumble's doing deals with people
uh rumbles doing
um you know I don't know exactly the
terms but some people are getting signed
and we're saying that a lot I think I
think Russell Brand did something I
think Bill come to me who are smaller
and say hey rumble's offering me a deal
should I do it I say what's the terms I
hear the terms I say I wouldn't do it I
think it's a bad deal and they will go
okay well you know I'm broke and so it's
money for me
stages in their life so people wonder
why it might make sense to sign it you
have to think about that's why the
individual person right but but are you
single and by yourself like at World
game was saying I wouldn't sign
something like that I like to be in
control of my business let's ask where
we met same question right when he has
four kids he just got married and
sometimes situation shifts and you're
like you know I actually want to lay
down some Roots when I started this
stuff seven years ago I would have never
signed a contract with daily wire ever I
was loving what I was doing on YouTube I
was enjoying my Independence I was you
know doing some part-time stuff with
Turning Point USA I was doing Fox News
shows five days a week you know and
literally six seven days a week
sometimes my life changed my life
changed where I wanted to put down some
Roots because I have children so that's
another part of this conspiracy land
where people I think people said to me
she doesn't go on Alex Jones anymore
they never mentioned that I also don't
go on Jesse Waters or Laura Ingram or I
literally do Tucker once a week it's
because I lit I don't have to I have two
kids now and I had Alex Jones on my show
last year right so everything becomes
this conspiracy and not that this person
is actually growing up got married has
two kids and doesn't have as much time
to manage an entire business right and
maybe you go actually I'd rather spend
that time with my kids Dr like the my
contact wire allows for me to wake up in
the morning to drop my kids off at
daycare to pick them up from daycare if
I want to to to to go back home to have
lunch with my son to that's a wonderful
thing because my motherhood is the most
important thing in my life has has the
daily wire ever
I shouldn't say instructed but insisted
that you don't talk about something no
we've had two we've had we've had two
content disagreements and I will be open
about it because I I believe a
transparency is the best way for people
to decide for themselves the first one
was during covet crazies like at the I
think by the time that I did your and I
was instantly against the vaccine 100
like didn't even play with it and I
wanted to do this thing talking about
how it was impacting people's
menstruation based on what I women that
had gotten the vaccine were telling me
one of my best friends who I just went
to go see here
um she just literally wouldn't stop
bleeding couldn't get it I mean it was
like girls were terrified and nobody
would talk about it and I was adamant I
mean I sat down there in that control
and I was like why are we doing the show
like you know if we're so afraid of and
this is one thing's where it's like okay
I get why they're saying they're like we
will like to their credit if you put
this on YouTube they've made it very
clear they all started making these
policies about the vaccine suddenly if
you said anything against the vaccine
and to me it would have been worth
losing a fee to talk about this because
I just wanted it to be on record and for
women to hear it and then eventually
they agreed and they said okay if you're
going to do it you do it by the book you
may be careful that you say that a
friend told me you know just making sure
that the language is exactly right and
that's what the editors are paid to do
to be like maybe this sentence can be
Strife so that we can we have a defense
for you on YouTube but I did say you can
go back and listen to the episode during
covet but it was a fight okay and of
course you gotta make sure to tell
everybody just talk to a medical
professional you know this is not
medical advice yeah exactly I had to
start with I'm not you know I'm not a
doctor I'm telling you what I am hearing
and what women are telling me and then
seven months later when we were all
Vindicated when they suddenly admitted
it in the Press I looked like a freaking
hero and I was like see guys like it
pays it to talk and it wasn't Jeremy and
Caleb there's obviously a lot of I don't
talk to Jeremy Camp all my shows the
second situation was with yay obviously
that was like a very big deal things
that were going on and they felt and
this actually was a conversation with
Jeremy and Caleb they basically were
like we would never tell you what to say
but what we are saying is that we're
under all this fire because whether
you're being silent or what you're
saying it seems like people are
interpreting this as this is a defense
of yay and we are just asking you like
okay you have made it clear that yay is
your friend I'm not going to not say I
made clear that I was not going to say
anything bad about yay I still feel very
passionate about that he is my friend I
actually believe in friendship I don't
believe in dropping recording if I have
said publicly he's my friend and because
I have said that I am not willing to
when the entire media is lashing him and
he's losing his entire life to to add to
the fire of everything and but then they
said something to me and it registered
where they said okay you're saying all
this stuff in defensive yay but what
about your other friends that might be
being hurt by this and that was when I
decided on my show to say something in
defense of Dennis Prager because I
realized that while I was defending yay
I also wasn't defending people which is
also very important to me my friends
like Marissa straight Marissa straight
CEO of prayer Q I worked for them but
she is much more than that to me like
she is like a sister to me I went
through some very very serious stuff A
couple of years ago which I wouldn't
even care to recap it's one of those
situations where you're just like it's
like life or death you know what I mean
like am I I'm gonna get my half in the
morning and the only person I spoke to
that got me through that was Marissa
straight and I would never deny that I'm
friends with Mr straight and I would
never deny that I am friends with yay
and sometimes these two things at this
moment seem to run into conflict and
they were just like you know
alarm Bells being you know why are you
only saying stuff about yay not saying
whatever and all I did was say exactly
what I just said to you I'm French both
these people and that doesn't make sense
to the world at this moment I get that
but I I refuse to say anything bad about
either of them so this is this is a
really good point because
um like I said I think the daily wires
are not positive we took a different
approach to the a thing after yay
stormed out of here we sent a reporter
to go hang out with him and get the
story uh Shane Cashman went down hung
out with them and it was an amazing
story and he called it the case for
president yay call that a defense or
whatever you want to call it I you know
when I talked to him I was like he he
invited Shane to come out and do this
interview in depth in person to
experience you know what he was working
on uh it was it was really great and I
said you know and and I'm talking to
Shane as yays on Infowars saying very
outrageous things and then we were like
what do we do and I'm like do you still
want to do it he was like yeah I'm like
have fun bro like write it up do it to
it yeah uh and that's and that's a
moment that we're in and by the way
correctly why that's a very difficult
scenario to sort of maneuver you have
one of your hosts that's like you know
about yay and the other was like he's my
friend and so I think that that should
show a credit a credit to the Daily wire
that we were both able to say what we
felt to be true and I've always said
like Shapiro can say what he wants and
what he believes they don't become my
beliefs we disagree about a lot of
different things and the yay situation
was a scenario in which we disagreed and
let me tell you the pressure that was
put on me from the mainstream media
tweets all the stuff to say something
bad about yay like to just say one thing
bad about him and it's me you know it
was sadistic and I stood up for someone
because you know I I refused rather than
saying stop for him I refuse to add to
it because it seems sadistic it was like
how much more do you need somebody to be
hit over the head he's like bleeding on
the ground I got nothing left and
there's like a walk of shave yeah they
just wanted me and then I realized
because it was like everyone has said it
the entire world said his wife has said
it this person said they've taken
everything from him they're threatening
to to psych 5150 him all this stuff but
we need Candace to say it and I was like
this is now sadistic and I am not going
to participate in this and then it
became well if you don't participate
then we're gonna whip you too you know
and I was like f all of you because at
the end of the day every single day my
goal is to put my head in the pillow and
know that I was a decent human being
okay and that is why I don't have very
many enemies so shockingly in this
movement because I stand by what I
believe in always even when it's popular
not to do that it would have been so
easy for me to sell yay down the river
and be like well this situation and
Martyr but it's like no man like
sometimes just hold the line be a person
and wait for people to move on and and I
I don't need you to understand how I'm
both friends with yay and both friends
with Marissa Street I want to say uh one
one final thought as we we start to wrap
this up uh
I've known crowded for a while he's
always been really nice to me
um I've been on the show several times
and uh I I like the guy I think it is
important work I also know Jeremy boring
and in all of the business dealings that
I've done with a bunch of companies the
best was with Jeremy despite the fact we
did not come to any formal transactional
understanding just doesn't make sense
but I I think the conversation was an
important one to have because we're
exploring how can we do better by this
everything that's going on we want to
win the culture War I I do think
Jeremy's a good dude and you know I've
talked with people at big companies
obviously I talked with advice I've
talked with Fusion I've talked with a
bunch of other big New York media and
they all you want you walk out every
time going yeah yeah yeah
when I when I when I went to the Daily
wire and was talking with Jeremy it was
like this is fun is hanging out talking
brainstorming and we ultimately decided
that there's probably nothing we could
do but we'll we'll do non-transactional
things like the Times Square billboard
stuff since then there have been periods
where I've talked with Jeremy and like
hey look we're a small company we've had
this problems and he's like oh yeah you
know he's giving me like free advice
without question just seriously helping
another company which arguably is a
competitor and so I I think Jeremy's a
great dude so it's really hard for me
I'm like I don't want everybody fighting
I don't think daily wire is a bad
company I don't think steam Crowder is a
bad dude I think there's an ideological
disagreement it's really difficult I
don't know how to solve the problem yeah
but what's your gut instinct telling you
because I'm I'm not going to let you be
agnostic you've got the facts in front
of you you're watching the videos like
what is your gut telling you about this
it was wrong for Crowder to record
Jeremy I'm shocked to see that he he
registered stop VidCon a month before he
recorded the phone call which says that
he's been planning this for some time I
do think Stephen Crowder is
ideologically motivated I I don't think
it's effective right now with what's
going on to go after the daily wire when
you have things like Disney and Netflix
to be angry about the daily wires
producing stuff that I think is very
important and good notably the
documentary you did on BLM notably the
documentary Matt Walsh did uh uh what is
a woman
and so I'm just like is this the
appropriate thing to be doing I don't
know if Crowder should be I do think
that uh
Crowder is right in that these contracts
are not good for people starting up that
being said I do understand like Brett
Cooper is probably infinitely better off
because of it you know what I mean it's
a difficult thing it's a difficult thing
of course I didn't know who Brett Cooper
was and now I'm like she's amazing like
her show is so great and so and and that
video recording that Crowder has I just
heard it for the first time with this
video Jeremy's right she's gonna work
for him
and she's going to leave very famous and
she's going to be worth millions of
dollars after that fact I recognize that
Luke Luke told me a while ago before I
worked for Disney not to do it I said
yeah but look I worked for them for a
couple years I get paid a lot of money I
can invest in another company and I
ended up doing that and I had a really
bad experience really really quickly but
I did get paid enough money to start all
of this so it's like maybe it's easy to
join the Disney cult the Mickey Mouse is
not good for you Tim don't do it the
dark side is too strong to the
corporation he's another he can he can
put himself in the presence of the
emperor and still maintain the light but
hey hey Star Wars so easy but this is my
version of these contracts it was two
years where the company instantly went
woke and it locks you up and I'm like
so I I think my ultimate view is
I don't I don't I don't think Crowder
should be waging this in a way that's
damaging to the Daily wire but I do
think he should be leading a charge and
changing the business landscape of the
space and then you know there's a net
positive way to do it I I would have
thought you would have been bigger and
better if you didn't sign into a Disney
you would have been on your own and you
would have been two years ahead of where
you are that's entirely that's entirely
possible and that's why I was like don't
do it no imagine if I just started doing
this show instead of going and working
there and being stuck for two years I
think your experience inside the belly
of the Beast is invaluable but but hey I
had nowhere to sleep whose couch would I
be sleeping on when you were covering
all those crazy protests right I needed
so I'm happy that happened now you know
what I'll say is my view of it is this
I think the daily wire is
going to be a media Enterprise and it's
going to look like you're going to see
two hot rods one's got a pride flag on
it one's got a Gadsden flag on it
they're both hot rods okay me I'm not a
hot rod guy I don't drive those things
you know I'm gonna get my electric
motorbike and or a moped or something
I don't got beef with people who you
know who who are driving hot rod but you
know I'd rather hang out with the guys
got the Gadsden flag thing am I going to
buy the car no am I going to you know
pay to drive around in it no but I think
it's cool that you got it and I'd rather
that than the other one you know what I
mean so that being said I'm just looking
at a mathematical formula
if the daily wire succeeds is it good
for us 100 yes absolutely is it the
system I would build no it's absolutely
not and but I like the daily wire you
know what I mean I watched I watch
Disney stuff I stopped subscribing I
don't have a Netflix Netflix
subscription either I don't fault people
for wanting entertainment we have to
build the machine we want to see and
then people can leave so if Crowder in
my opinion wants to make something where
he thinks he can do better contracts my
Approach if I was him would be guys I
tried doing a deal with these companies
I think their deals are bad I understand
they produce content that's probably
good here's what I'm gonna do I'm going
to make a machine that's better I'm
gonna do better contracts for you quite
literally that is what I'm doing that's
literally all he had to say but let's go
to the members only section because we
got to talk about so much so uh thanks
so much for hanging out I know it's
contentious there's like people like
Crowders right DW is right but we'll
have Crowder on the show Monday and then
he'll he'll lay out his case and his
view of everything smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends we're going to go to
timcast.com talk uncensored members only
so again go to timcast icon click the
join us button and we'll see over there
you can follow the show at timcastirl
you can follow me at timcast Candace you
want to shout anything out uh just my
podcast I feel like that's appropriate
I'm very proud of what we're doing it's
amazing we explore all of these topics
I'm obviously very passionate about
against vaccines I'm very passionate
about the corruption of the CIA I'm very
passionate about
um all of the WWF stuff the globalist
actually everything that you were
talking about so my podcast is about I
usually don't talk about
um conservative infighting I do try to
stay out of it but and then just to say
to people like please don't think
everything is a conspiracy don't think
that every person is selling out we're
never going to win if if your
perspective is that one simple thing
that you don't understand means that
somebody has sold out or one simple
agreement that you have please don't
think that every single person has the
same opinion at the daily wire I'm still
the exact same person that you invested
in your timing when you hit the share
button when I back when I was red pill
black nothing has changed I'm just a mom
now I have two kids and I don't agree
with everything that the daily wire does
but this time I didn't do anything wrong
hey what's the best place for people to
get the podcast Apple Spotify wherever
you listen you can watch the show on
YouTube as well if you want to watch it
every single day I think um the YouTube
channel they started for me is Candace
Owens pod I also have my own YouTube
channel
um which is separate and yeah I run my
social media accounts my Instagram my
Twitter are not controlled by the daily
wire like that conspiracy and I'm still
friends with everybody so for people
that think that oh she forgot her well
it's nope still friends with every
single person two shows I've been on I
don't have beef in this movement because
people that are chill with me I have
nothing bad to say about them even if
other people hate them what's your
Twitter really quickly at real Candace
oh only because Candace was taken and
it's never been tweeted from so Elon
Musk Hear My Cry release all of the
unused handles and give me at Candace I
had to shoot my shot I had to shoot my
shot
yeah
maybe I'll talk to him later anyway my
website is Luke casual look uncensor.com
is my website I am fully independent and
you can support me there I go off into
the deep deep deep deep down the rabbit
hole on a lot of crazy stuff a lot of
solutions a lot of ways to not be
victims of the state look uncensored.com
is the website see you there and Ian
Arthur Crossland that's me are you
working out with me tomorrow no come on
I'm in without I'm trying to start a
fight I'm trying to do like some
kickboxing with Ian trying to start a
fight wait I know like like a fight club
like a nice one I just did 20 push-ups
before the show though
dude I'm getting big that's my plan for
2023 what I do is I post it on Twitter
and then I pin it what I'm gonna do that
year and then every time I go on Twitter
I see my resolution and I'm reminded
this year I'm building muscle I do a
kickboxer I'm like we gotta do this
every morning 4 30 a.m oh that's awesome
yeah
I got no one to work out with me dude
I'm in I wanted to clarify we talked
about the ozone layer and things that
were ripping it open in the 80s and 90s
it was CFCs you were right
chlorofluorocarbons different than pfcs
which are polyflorides yeah those are
Plastics that are destroying me yeah and
the chlorofluorocarbons were in like
Hairspray and stuff so we got rid a lot
of that and but I think the ozone well
let's just talk about this stuff well
yeah well it's getting late love you man
yo love you too Ian uh my name is
assert.com I was on the podcast the uh
what is it called pop culture podcast
culture crisis we did speak by Alec
Baldwin as well
um went kind of deep with that but uh
yeah that's just fun I forgot to mention
it yesterday so shout out pop culture
price crisis uh yeah ready for the after
show all right everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.com we WE Post the
uncensored members only to the front
page around 10 50 11 p.m we'll probably
go a little bit later because we went
late for this one but we'll see you all
there thanks for hanging out cheers